of course yeah give it a second
no worries well yeah I'll be back in
just a second he's got a little bit of
company this morning outside of his home
and that would be our wonderful
wonderful men and women who help out
unfortunately they've just make a lot of
noise yeah man they it looks like a lot
of people were excited for flashpoint
there's like I heard you started always
flashpoint
ybox is what is going on man you don't
bro oh man it's a crazy week there's
been a lot that's happened Game Awards
happened last night trailer of all
trailers drops this morning we've got
people freaking out we've got the
fastest reaction from Bungie probably
ever seen on anything it's been quite a
week so as always we've got a lot to
talk about
yes we do oh man obviously uh getting
that destiny to grind with you shout-out
to uh Wilhelm scream got some gaming at
him with ham shout to Chi Basu you know
everybody been getting a chance to play
with me on PC shout to um small point
which is the clan right now that I'm
associated with aka flashpoint but up
now shout out to uh those guys man Mike
Ibarra and cruel good group of guys to
run wid and just taking me under the
wing for a little bit and oh shout to
MJ's a boss in the chat he's got destiny
to and I'm PC as well but um yeah it's
been real fart man and just trying to
catch I'm still behind you know I'm in
the 500 but um you know get a chance to
run with a bot is who let me tell y'all
real quick Long Point oh yeah probably
gonna have a lot to talk about guys so
real quick
this man has always told me how PvE is
his staying I really stepped foot in the
crucible you know that's you cognate I
jump into a crucible match with this man
he is mopping the floor with people his
life
it's like he's got like a 30-piece like
regular I'm like dude you yeah he's the
dude that he's like yeah I don't really
fight I don't really I don't really
train it gets out daily Achmat shoo and
mops everybody like you probably have to
remember the fact that you meet joining
you somehow affects like skill badge
making so I'm sure the same thing
happens with my brother sometimes he
doesn't play that much PvP either and I
don't know what his flight levels are at
or anything but like there's times I'll
play by myself and I'll turn around and
I will get work but they don't play with
some other people and sometimes I'll
have games where it goes well it's fine
yeah it does but and then there's plenty
- trust me there's times where I'm like
oh sweet I got like a 30-piece and then
I feel like I got a one of 30 like I
died 30 times so it was like it's go
both ways but I mean I have some games
but I'm not going to claim to be like
anybody who's amazing in the competitive
world I promise you that's a different
animal so Blizz this guy I was just in
his backpack I would say I'm just happy
to be here I'm probably to be a part of
his team so I can be carried literally
here in shock - scream - screams pudding
work with you hey you guys were going
crazy man you don't say so I'm still
trying to figure out my loadout so I
literally don't have any exotics yet you
know I'm saying but in any of my like
prime pvp weapons so I gotta give myself
some excuse we gotta work on that a
linked quest so we can get to at least
borealis yeah I mean you started Eve
refer-a-friend quest so that's cool you
gotta get that going I saved the story
mission uh what you call it um critical
thing so we can do that but I'm not but
overall managed it's been real fun just
loving a glorious glorious nosov it on
PC having a great time just grinding
what kinda box we're trying to get you
know stuff back trying to get things
completed and obviously we will talk
about what we're trying to get it
completed for then what we try to level
for and perspectives on next so how to
talk about that yeah
heads up to everybody out there this is
just a complete total sidebar if you're
fans of the Marvel movies and you do
like trailers if you want no spoilers
obviously avoid the internet but if you
want to Emma say I don't think it spoils
much not much if you watch in
you know if you watched adventure
Avengers infinity war the new trailer
dropped and I cannot wait for that movie
dude insane and game and game yeah if
you're a fan of the series man this is
what it's about so this is a childhood
stuff for me and like I grew up on those
comics Infinity Gauntlet you know
affinity war all that stuff man Thanos
the whole thing so just to see this
thing in this in real time on the big
screen it's just I'm a kid again man so
it's great yeah it's gonna be one of
those I'm like alright buying the button
tickets as soon as they come out find a
way to see it some crazy like midnight
showing probably of course all this
stuff is gonna be a thing so of course
yep that's gonna be huge Game Awards
happen last night I didn't want to shout
that out as well cuz it was pretty cool
and shout out to what I was hoping would
win because for me it honestly is my
game here and God of War it's game day
here game director and game of the year
and honestly it's well deserved a place
so much destiny it's hard for me to
sometimes step away for other games like
to really like spend some time and dive
deep and then or if I do pick it up to
not be drawn back into destiny mm-hmm
either God of War came out of the
perfect time or whatever it was but I
could not put it down like I finished
and I blasted through I was telling you
about I was like dude you gotta get this
you gotta try it
mm-hm it's really really good it's
honestly and it was just well deserving
got Game of the Year and honestly I
can't imagine of what was up there they
were all pretty good games like Spider
Man I heard was really good Red Dead has
pieces a lot of like hyper Rockstar but
I mean I think it was a mixed bag on
that one and I think ditch sound like
some lashade hold on I never said it was
amazing cameo and I LP with that slander
good job it's just one of those that
like I picked it up played it for a
little bit but then it's like me as much
as I do destiny I wasn't as driven to go
back in I have not
I played it that much so it's like
because I I heard and I know how
daunting it is yeah because it's one of
those where it's like it's really really
really long it's not like it's
Assassin's Creed Odyssey I know there's
some stuff in there where you got level
up through it's like it's this one it's
like it's gonna be slow people have
issues with certain things it's like it
is amazing to take it all in the
character growth of like the main you
know your main buddy is really really
cool but it's just like at the point in
comparison to the other game it just
wasn't for me at the moment at some
point I definitely want to cuz I got to
experience it but I think God of War was
just I picked it up and I couldn't put
it down and it was just the combat the
action the story it made me want to go
try and figure stuff about Norse
mythology I'm like what am i doing like
it was just that type of it was just
really really well done so now I hate
what you saying I don't have course I'm
teaching is one of these things and I
forgot who said it on Twitter shouting
oh boy J Fonz like a lot of games are
just so subjective at the end of date I
think what it is with this this year
which is such a high quality level in
that category one of the best years in
gaming with all these different great
titles and I think ultimately it came
down to what game touched you the most
you know Sam and I totally get it like
I'm kinda on your side though that like
God awards more my speed
you know I'm saying in the story and
cinematic storytelling and the action
and stuff like that and the controls in
the control it was a photo you know shot
the read the shot they still cleaned up
on other wards stuff like that shout
spider-man but your game Awards was late
last night a lot of stuff I know shout
out to destiny not being nominated on
any musical category yet again and I'm
gonna keep I'm gonna keep trumpeting
this man I listen whatever you feel
about the game I get it you guys can say
I'm a destiny stand I get it but one
cannot tell me with an objective mind
that destiny of the franchise has some
of the best music in gaming and it's a
travesty that that game does not get
nominated you know what I'm saying like
that oh it really kills all mesh out the
elder to the chat target
red beds in the Java I read this you two
got again listen I hear you man is a
good argument already know but listen
ready I did win a lot of awards so it's
not like they came empty-handed
and I'm saying they still want a lot of
what I believe they want a narrative
they warned they would a bunch man they
went about three or four and I say like
what got a war what about three I know I
caught two I didn't catch that much
unless it was because I thought God
wasn't gonna win watched a one two and
then when it came to game with a year I
already conceded that the way the show
was going that like read dad was gonna
win it and then when we got war my god
you know this I think it ended up being
maybe three to three or three to four in
a final count but still you don't both
games did well man yeah and well
deserved I mean they both had some very
high points each so hey there's a lot of
work put in by all the teams across all
of those so I mean just hats off to
everybody kick about this here I mean
and then as you said destiny as well as
like there's a lot of it may not appease
everybody's palates on a lot of some
things here some things there but
there's if there's some things that
destiny does it so well and I mean it
got a little nomination for the what
does it ongoing game or whatever they
classify yeah I mean going against
fortnight of course yeah that's know
nothing has a chance but exactly I mean
there are definitely some things destiny
does really really well and it's hard to
argue that so for sure I mean music you
know art that type of stuff so many
there are some things they do extremely
well they definitely they definitely
deserve some credit so after you man how
I shouted Corey Belvoir log great guy
got a chance to physically meet him at
e3 and have a conversation good guy man
we chopped it up he was so appreciative
so yeah shout out to Corey bar work
shout Sony Santa Monica
fantastic game reimagine the franchise
and yeah it was a great game was I
enjoyed it I drove myself all right well
I think that little intro is probably
enough so the first piece I do yeah
we're just gonna jump into this we'll
get some other stuff a little bit later
but yeah the first weeks happened
black armories first forge and quest is
is out there in the universe more of it
drops today actually in about three
hours so from what you've seen so far I
want to ask forward from what you've
seen I like your terms what I've seen
what I've heard what I've laid yeah what
do you feel so far about this uh much
yeah
you know me you've talked offline yeah
you know it's it's it's it's a misstep
it's a misstep and um I'm not I don't
want to go crazy hard on them obviously
you know I feel you know forsaken was
great and I'm not gonna make excuses for
them either but I did Paul Tess he shot
the poet a Stephen Forbes he said it
best and I think the problem of black
armory is an onboarding issue I wish I
could comment on the DLC because I
really haven't accessed much of on PC
yes so listen I understood my plight you
know I came from console to you know to
a PC with only a few days maybe three
days to try to get ready and that's
coming from you know 300 light you know
when a forsaken boost so to speak right
so you know I knew that it was gonna I
wasn't realistically gonna be ready so
my thing was okay let me see what they
do for guys less in my situation if
there's anything I noticed it wasn't any
spark of light kind of a deal where you
can get to the level of 600 okay fine
that's because I was willing to pay I'll
be honest you know I knew I was that far
behind put on all right that's not
that's not there but then I looked at it
and I started to judge you guys like the
screams the you know the ibadis is you
know the Sinister is all my guys that
are 600 sitting at Schilling and when I
hear stories about you guys and I'll let
you continue this part you know that's
the part where I'm just like wow like if
you guys are having issues then I don't
know what what to say so the only thing
you know in conclusion with my quote air
quotes experience with black for me is
that you know there needed to be
something in place and
to come out and check they needed be
something in place as far as the level
access because my issue is this I don't
like hearing stories of the deal new DLC
is out but I can't do anything in the
new DLC I have to now grind existing old
content that I've been grinding just to
now play attempt to play the new content
like cuz that's much I just want to see
something new you know realistically all
I did was you know me and Kyle we went
to spider spider I said hey go to ADA
you talk to ADA
and I'm like okay but at the end of the
day it was like I didn't really get a
chance to really do the new content and
pry and pass destinies the issue has
always been when the content comes out
there's usually a campaign that campaign
kind of gets you set up for the end game
the other problem with black armory
there's no soft cap so your blues are
still giving you 600 like that's a
problem like that to me was over
excessive and I get it you know people
gonna say oh you can't have it both ways
you guys complained about crying
explaining about grind but the thing is
black arm is just not consistent with
past destiny DLCs so that's my issue
like did it just went this new extreme
curve you know and I'm saying with um
you know with the whole thing so that
that's what it is and you know I'm dying
to hear your perspective because I know
obviously you were of level and let you
know break it down for me how you feel
about this whole thing uh okay so yeah I
mean you know how much I play and I know
how much you play if you were still not
trying to work on the PC grind if you're
on console you've been in the same spot
but you trying to get that PC grind
because guess what hashtag converted
it's like when you make that switch just
the feel of things when you come over to
console or come over you see and then
you even try and be like hey what's
going on on console Oh what is this
like it's a hard switch to go back to so
yeah set up for you powering through on
PC not being like I know I'm my
characters gonna the other one I'm gonna
go back to console real quick cuz it's
hard it's really hard to go back so I'm
just
right now I would keep it about like
what you don't gave me the caviar you
get come on you gave me a mansion a
limousine now you telling me to to go
back to the Black Knight
no I'm just well you won't so as I said
told you and that's an honestly that is
shout out to the team who have worked on
the PC port it is me thought it is just
smooth testing it's just like a little
crispier a little fancier a little
shinier but it is still vesti in every
beat like it is one of these I know it I
can't even call it a port it's just a
the PC build of destiny is spot on and
just feels a little bit better cuz it
can that's it I mean it's it's destiny
and just in the loading times the
there's little stuff you notice like
when you do your super just the effects
on you or just a little bit more
grandeur and stuff so all of those
pieces just shout out to the PC team on
that and that's why I wanted you I mean
you've been consul for life and the fact
that you're not it's like that just says
it all so yeah absolutely man I did junk
you say it fantastic point port port is
amazing but continuing your experience
to hold ahead
so yeah I mean my experience like many
people's was as follows and we're gonna
cover reactions by people or even cover
reactions by destiny we're gonna cover
how this content is gonna go out so all
of this is gonna be discussed but this
is just my log in to black armor
experience when I got home from work yes
sir so you you log in yes you said you
go to spider first you pick up your
little card you go to ADA who is very
very very torn about working with you or
not like unfortunately we don't know why
mm-hmm I was like there's Laura that I'm
sure by for somebody's gonna find on a
weapon that will explain it which will
be great I'll be curious to hear that
one but I don't know specific is for me
logging in I don't get an experience or
an understanding as to why she is so
torn as to why she's she's like okay you
have this magical card so I have to help
you but I'm really torn about doing it
but now that you're helping me do I help
you does it help the black armory but
I'm really going against like the
founder of the black armory who the hell
is that guy and what happened before
that's what I want to know that's what
I'm like no let me actually can ask you
a question about that - yeah I heard
okay
and clarify things I'm sha Dion mial
alright now when didn't did go blow up
the tower or no like this is a new tower
it is the older I can't remember like
what what happened is this the rebuilt
tower or this was the tower that was
always there from existing the reason
what I'm asking is that how is this
chick down there nobody don't know about
any of this
semen that's what some are basically
asking and saying and to me it feels
like I mean for them to rebuild the
tower it's still a lot looks like the
tower but I mean they may be a real bit
rebuilt the upper structures cuz that's
probably got what shot with the missiles
maybe the lower structures were okay
I don't know is that's our next to the
old town yeah I'm just curious just like
cuz I get it just feels like you know
how do we have this being and all this
this this whole place and is like how do
we not know of this it literally was so
quick to get down there which is like go
that escalator God step here she is of
like what I didn't expect it to be there
I'll be honest that's us yeah and I
think some people are saying like you
know it where it where is it gonna be oh
it's in the tower okay so yeah it's just
kind of one of those there's there's
some questions as to but I mean it's
like where do you who's there in the
walls they're all walls
thank you scream I know exactly Shia
it's one of those pieces it's like I
mean but where do you put it though
because you could kind of you know
shoehorn it into some cave on a planet
or something else I mean this is in a
hub and shout out to them they actually
put another landing zone in the tower
specifically just for this so that's
actually kind of cool you may not
actually see it yet because you haven't
actually finished the quest yeah but
once you actually kind of talk to her
for the first time and can I get the
card piece you've actually got a landing
zone with her switch is quicker xx path
back back there which is nice but anyway
you go to her you get the card she's
really torn you're like okay I've got
these things to go do they're not really
difficult
there's efficient ways to do it but even
if you do it naturally it probably might
take you an hour - not that long but if
you really knock it out it's like 3045
minutes it can go pretty damn quick then
you come back and be like hey the full
under fords which yet we all knew from
the calendar was going to be this is
what launched
like okay go have your first experience
in the forge now this is day one things
have changed
literally from day one to day two but
day one it says recommend power 16 and
I'm like all right I'm 600 cool mmm 10
levels I should be able to at least try
it maybe have some struggles and this is
one of those points to where Bungie does
this type of thing it's the same thing
they did on last witch raid the same
thing they've set on other things they
say recommended power level now if you
say recommended power level for an
activity that better chores how mean
recommend a power level for what it
takes for me to do the activity not to
walk into it because you can walk into
the black LaForge you like take a little
different path up off of the sunken
island up top and ebz you drive down
there you go in there you shoot some
dudes you're like oh I actually survived
that cool mm-hmm
then you actually boot up the 4gl this
got a little harder and then you get to
the second wave of the forge and you're
like I'm getting my butt whooped right
now then like I mean I did it with
randoms the first couple times and I
actually saw the boss on about my third
where try it was like had some issues I
got the concept and then third try was
like I can't even touch this guy yeah
and I even like on one of my builds I
was like okay let me move some stuff
around while I'm waiting for matchmaking
to go brought whisper tried to sit there
in the corner and kind of they were
working on him and I was working on and
I still got a decent chunk of him down
yeah she like 3/4 of his health and I
was like what is happening right now I
cannot tell you so I mean when it
started it launched at 6:10 but
basically that's the initial guys that
you go see then as soon as you kick off
the event it was 6:15 the second wave
was 25 and then the boss was 6:30 a.m.
so that 630 was far enough for people
who would literally like what do you
want to do when you log into a game see
the new quest go right into that new
activity and try it out let me back you
up one second explain to me because I've
not watched any videos on it you know um
I've been purposely staying with explain
to me what the mechanics are like when
you put it in there what do you got to
do mechanics are pretty pretty
straightforward you're gonna have ads
that's fun and you're gonna have have
you seen any of the saboteurs out in the
world
the blue shielded ones yeah I saw one
yes yes yes so basically those that
shield ish color the blue shield not the
little drones but they're gonna have
that color when you kill those guys they
drop batteries their little balls and
you have to throw them into the forge
that's kind of floating in the middle
and you're working on throwing those
batteries in to start charging it up so
as you kill an enemy they drop something
you throw it into the Forge and you got
to do 20 of those batteries per wave
okay you start with a set number of time
I don't know if it's 30 seconds 40 50 a
minute but it ticks down as you throw
batteries in it gives you a little bit
of time not a ton but a little so if
you're kind of going in a consistent
rate you should do okay if you're
struggling you might you know fail it on
the first time so - yeah you don't run
down to the mechanics that's phase one
okay the things that you'll have it's
all COBOL in there everything is cabal
in this thing so you're gonna have first
the ones that you need to kill are gonna
be either the gladiators your big sore
guys those will drop - because they take
a ton of ammo to drop more you've got
the scions which used it a little bit
easier those are usually your first two
on this on wave 1 wave 2 you're gonna
have legionaries or colossi which you
know how I'm a hard colossi are normally
much less when they're shielded have a
boatload of ammo and that's brutal
right so those are it's the escalation
for one of the enemy types you have to
kill and then to kill and Colossus over
and over just the fact that they're
gonna wreck you really fast any fast
yeah yeah so artsy and my chat is
actually saying with killing the blue
guys I don't know if it's killing them
or throwing the battery in the middle
either way it's definitely related to
those guys and then the third one boss
comes out it is this huge huge dude with
missile launchers and just he just
absolutely wrecks my face is he bigger
than the glitch for the thing no sidebar
just so if you guys hadn't seen
Bungie fixed and that's why the inverted
spire was out basically inverted spires
boss and I forget
his name it's not directly on because
that's what inverted spire because the
one he falls down three times yeah
whatever his his name is he's the big
one of the big nothing mind or something
oh yeah yeah yeah something like that um
he was a big boy he was three times the
size he was supposed to be he looked
like a transformer yes he was huge
yes mega cha he was absolutely massive
so that is definitely a hilarious and I
wish I could have seen it and sometimes
I honestly was just one at every ten
times all bosses would be like big boy
mode like it would just be hilarious
hilarious
it may be when it's big boy mode do you
have like a monthly of like a 50% chance
for that strike exclusive to drop a
really funky thing to see I think if
you're gonna go yeah so anyway we go
back in but I basically did this at 600
the first time I tried the first porch
and this is the whole under forge and I
just kept dying I did it like three
times and I died and I'm like alright so
that's kind of the end of my experience
so that's literally about my first hour
and a half trying the new content so 600
you're saying you were not it was not
enough
nope not to start the new stuff correct
Wow mm-hmm
now full disclosure Bungie on Wednesday
because that's when I turned around and
actually did beat it they heard feedback
if they heard from everybody but they
didn't like completely pull the rug out
from under the forge
they lowered it by five and within that
day I had done a couple grinds I had put
in some powerful engrams things like
that and it was and I was able to knock
it out at about 604 with a couple people
at least talking and kind of have an
idea what's going on
so I did knock it out the next day they
had lowered it down so then it became
610 6 26 25 so those pieces were a
factor getting to about 605 is kind of a
thing you're going for so if you were
600 it's trying to go to 605 now this is
where you're yeah EJ well if I got you
for sure
this is where tasks you said this is the
onboarding of new content what they are
trying to do right now is sell and I
know I'm talking a lot so I'm gonna let
you go you're the one that experienced
the content you need yeah
so they're trying this is in here was my
question Mike remember when I was like
hey how's black armory there's a lot of
weight on the shoulders of black armory
how's it gonna go
the kind of stubbed their toe at the
start because a whole lot of people
jumped it was like hey let me do the new
stuff well crap I have to do old
grinding to get to do the new stuff this
is this is this what I really want to
feel and almost turn people off on day
one and that's where Paul Tassie's
article about the onboarding is there a
different way you could have set this up
and me my question was like okay so you
have four forges you could totally do
difficulty modes there are ways to make
this first Forge preach get like 600 605
610 like make it something that's doable
get a feel for the mechanic start a
quest start the grinding being
reasonable because today we get a new
Forge maybe this one's up at like 6:30
cool you know at least you got one you
can work on pretty much the point I know
they wanted it to be in-game activities
and I'm totally fine with that but as
the soft cap and this is there's things
they're evaluating we'll get to those
with them like that but their initial
lunch with a soft cap state of 500 up to
550 which is still 50 levels away prime
Grant engrams we're helping you get up
there a little quicker but from 550 to
600 especially 590 to 600 that's a long
grind in itself yeah you know I know
there's a grind and this is kind of the
other side as well I watched the fire
team chat yeah what if I can't drive
said I missed it my easy washroom was oh
yeah they did their opinions they
probably did it I think almost on the
first day before the change even came
out Oh
so there's was a quick reaction just
basically because you know there's a
whole lot going on and I like on it it's
it's kind of a back and forth like
Destin was saying it's like what is this
crap going on Sean was saying it's like
it's in-game you're supposed to be up
there at the top and this is like me
coming from World of Warcraft so say
you're going through an expansion and
hey you've been playing World of
Warcraft for you know it's like somebody
like you you jumped into World of
Warcraft you will work at a level on up
your character you're halfway through
the current expansion and the new
expansion dropped do you think you could
do the new expansion content when that
initially dropped no no but and that's
kind of one of those pieces where it's
like okay so this is meant to be this is
PO this is post 600 content they never
set a level so I mean some clarification
on that could have helped right but it's
also people just expect like hey I'm
gonna be able to jump in and do the
story mission exactly because those
previous story missions were like they
would have been like 540 or something
pretty basic right it'd be black armor
story missions or something you can do
this is your in-game like activity this
is like you're blind well this is your
escalation protocol dropping on day one
and you're meant to be max level from
the previous stuff already so if you
weren't there and hadn't grinded up this
stuff isn't is available to you now to
the counterpoint in that what world of
warcraft will do what a new expansion
comes out mm-hmm you can get a boost up
to that level holler that's what I was
looking for I was interesting what I was
like where is the boost where where's
the boost oh hey I was willing to pay
that hard cash to get to 600 because I
didn't want to grind again I mean there
are there are ways to balance it maybe
you get up to 590 you do a little bit of
something or just like what they say I
mean the soft cap of 500 so everything
was still just Bremen prime engrams and
powerful gear drops was it was it's a
slow grind and people have been working
there and that's kind of the thing every
a lot of people said and I mean I have
the same thoughts it's like so I've been
grinding up I'm at 600 and I got here
from 600 from doing all these grindy
things from powerful gears daily
challenges raids like whatever it was
and then you're gonna say it's like hey
before you do this new thing you got to
do some more that old stuff okay exactly
the biggest point you gotta go repeat
stuff you've done for weeks and weeks
and weeks before you can actually even
the succeed at the first thing
and that's what doesn't feel good it
just doesn't feel good doesn't like no
one you don't buy a new shiny item you
never mean to be forced to use the old
one over again before you can you know
touch the new one and it was just again
a simple fix like you said you know with
that first foolish maybe you bring that
first voyage down to 600 flat you give
people a taste of the content you give
them a feel they're in there they're
like yeah we got it in there all right
cool right up to the next one then the
next one is that jump like you know and
it's like okay man we're not ready you
know and then you go grind and I think
the other issue is a second issue which
is I think they needed I understand this
is a focus on end game activity but I do
think even though they're not doing a
campaign they needed another activity
that's new that allows you to grind wait
I think maybe whether if may like you
know if they didn't have a new strike
but maybe if they had strikes some other
activity that you can blind well or
whatever it is right that's new so that
you feel like you're doing new stuff
it's one of the worst feelings in the
world to just buy new content and not
being able to play and that's the part
that sucks for me you know Sam but I
understood it as a rookie but I'm
hearing this from other people who are
600 and I'm like the only T people I
heard what you said was t-rex and a
couple other guys right that were like
somebody's 650 already yeah like that
did tricks you don't say like what's
happening is now is the community is
having the scheme right they like
holding iron banner engrams from way
back you know say like all these tricks
that's not how the game should be
designed you know say so that's my issue
and you know look they they did jump
they did we'll get a get into that you
know as far as it the update your table
you know as far as a minor thing but you
know six oh five my question to you is
what did you even feel about when they
did you know they brought it down to
five the five level so this is just kind
of their this is their way to not nerf
the activity mm-hmm so it's too easy
because this is kind of the big thing we
run into and this is why the debate was
last wish was kind of
important piece right because last
wishes difficulty was for those who
grinded really hard but it was like they
set that out there because they I mean
when you watch the raid along they talk
about that people go in hey play for a
week see what this feels like where do
you get to and they had people play like
a lot a little here see where people
ended up in light level and that's where
they placed that braid to know that it
was gonna be a challenge
right these raids are meant to truly be
a challenge now that people are 650
might be mopping the floor with the raid
because they've been doing all the
saving and stuff like that but for most
people they want that raid that's really
be a challenge I want that first day to
really be a thing I get that and the
raid can still be that mm-hmm
that's okay if I know the raids are
farther grind and I know it's not gonna
be something I get to as soon and that's
okay but if the activities in in the
annual pass are just as hard to get to
and you have to play tricks to be able
to be successful at them mm-hm that's
kind of an issue right so no it's like
for me it was it's the whole it's them
trying to bounce the of how difficult do
we make this activity so it still feels
like an in-game activity but in turn
what is it gonna feel like when
somebody's 600 and so it's like I want
somebody at Bungie to explain to sit
down and on day one not the level it's
at now with heads up so you guys know
now we'll get to in a little bit but
basically what Bungie did on Wednesday
they dropped everything by five levels
mm-hmm so when they made that five level
drop some people would be like okay if
they still wanted to do it which is a
huge caveat there if they still wanted
to do that black armory Forge they'd
probably grind it a little bit down some
daily challenges some weekly stuff they
may have got up to 602 603 and lowering
it down about five if you had people
that kind of work together it was doable
so five levels if you have made it to
like 602 three or four meter so about
605 you were probably in a good spot as
screen widths and so if I was kind of a
good tipping point if you could have
gotten to there it's doable but it's
that as you said it's that first taste
first impressions are huge and
unfortunately the first impression on
this annual pass people are like what in
the world is happening now the counter
to that is they truly told you that
here's this calendar
all this stuff is gonna drop over time
but again it's that first one and this
most important part and that's where
they had a misstep without a doubt you
said it - it's that first impression
when I log into a quest I try it three
times with randoms and again here's why
matchmaking is going to be an issue try
and go play with randoms who don't know
what they're doing don't know the
strategies you can't really talk to them
cuz they're not in your chat and this is
why they don't put matchmaking and raids
go try matchmaking in this thing after a
little while and you're gonna understand
really fast yeah I mean you got me said
it right so this is the big thing and
this is how people are at 6:50 and
they're saving packages they're saving
powerful gear bounties they're doing all
of those things those are the people
that are up there if you had saved in
nothing yeah you might have gotten to
like six so if you've been playing a lot
603 604 605 never ate at 640 oh by the
way that's probably the suggested level
of 640 slide pectoralis that boss is 656
Cleveland I've clearly somewhere in
there it's gonna kill no I mean that
raid race is for the in the know lifers
I mean it is the streamers no lifers the
content creators I'm gonna call it what
it is that the manipulators and that's
the piece yeah those the ones that save
like cuz I actually on my warlock I
didn't even mean to do this
yeah I'm not entirely sure how I had
intentionally done it maybe I just done
done it with all other people and not
actually collect the bounty because I
was on 600 anyway I have I on my warlock
I had two previous like ascendant
challenge bounties not turned in but
finished wings like complete the bounty
and get the gear and I had those saved
on my warlock I haven't even touched him
yet but I was like I'm waiting till I
get to the point where I'm like okay
kind of done for the week I'm gonna
click on those three get them all
together give myself a little boost well
if you had six of those you had six you
could do six of the one and depending on
if there was that much of a rotation but
if you were maxed and you knew this is
come in you were to starting to save
these bounties you could do iron banner
you could have saved every piece of
every iron banner bounty that is what
seven yeah all of those things were a
way to save up bounties if you had the
time to grind and save it if you were
just working on getting up to 600 you
didn't save that stuff you turned it all
in so Guinness the people were max is
the no lifers who have those things in
now those are the people who have this
drastic advantage for the raid race
exactly and to me that's this is why I
have a problem again listen if you
figure our exploits to the system more
power to you I'm not knocking to hustle
you know you did what you had to do and
I'm saying from a Bungie standpoint is
you know I don't I don't I want to be
careful my word not I don't respect that
as like that guy is the best guy in the
community when it comes to world's first
you know it's just that because you've
got this exploit advantage if everybody
was on equal footing and nobody had
those you know what you call it's those
engrams and you know the cheese's or
whatever then let's see let's see
everybody going in with the 606 and see
what's really gonna happen you know that
that's my thing so again I kind of got a
look at these world's first situations
where I don't really feel it's
representative of the best players I
just feel it's the smarter players who
have figured out ways to exploit systems
and in my opinion that shouldn't be what
bungees intention for a world first rate
should be so they've got to fix the
system not just me and again I'm not
trying to disrespect any content creator
who 620 yeah you did what you had to do
I'm just saying for the overall
intention integrity of what world's
first should mean right like that that's
just not what it is to me I don't I'm
not looking at the attic in the JFX know
like I'm not I'm not looking at those
dudes like oh you're better than me
if I had the same right we all go in
there with 604 605 we're all gonna be
struggling just the same on that first
loss yep yeah I mean that's kind of
thing it's like World of Warcraft will
comment you have the new campaign and
stuff to do but it's not
you're three days later going the raid
or if you were you know everybody
started from the same place because
there's nothing there's no carry forward
quest that gets you new stuff there's
nothing like that so it was the new and
that's a difference of content and
pieces like that but that'd be the
points where like hey if I'm grinding
the forge that's how you get your higher
level stuff powerful engrams and things
or they should just say hey you can't
save up your stuff come you know when we
do the reset and when we take the
servers down for a half an hour for
black armory to lunch you can wipe out
everything but you're like what would
you call your progress on things like
Lunas Hal or brought rhetorics
broadsword those can stay no other
powerful gear bounties will stay in your
inventory and just wipe it clean no pret
no priming gram stay no powerful gear
doesn't matter it's all gone and that's
a way to just say hey wrap up your
season you're good what you're you get
and it's a fresh start for everybody I'm
surprised he because I remember quote me
if I'm mistaken
remember what forsaken launched like
they had all these measures to like to
stop people from doing kind of things
like this so I was actually surprised
that people was still able to figure out
ways to get past it like I remember they
had all these things they hey if you had
these engrams you held them that's not
gonna get you to the new light level if
you did this you did that and these
bounties is not they're gonna drop at
the old level so I was shocked that
people still was able to to do it to be
honest I don't know about you what was
that wasn't the case what forsaken or am
I mistaken like the previous grind I
think a lot of people did for stuff like
curse of Osiris I think that was a lot
of exotic grinds if I remember correctly
so I mean powerful bounty grinds
are I mean we've got a lot of new ones
now we've got the Dreaming city we
didn't have those before we've got the
iron banner those being powerful year
that wasn't always a thing you've got
your spider bounties those are all new
things that came with forsaken for
powerful gear it wasn't just the weekly
challenges things like that all of that
stuff is new so I mean the switch over
to how you got the grind before is
different so I mean caring from season 1
to season 2 they changed a lot of
systems are not seasoned what your what
your - they changed a lot of systems
so you didn't have as many places to do
it now you do mmm
fair enough fair enough yeah I mean
that's the point where they've got it
they have got it they've they really
need to as you're saying I mean for
world's first jackets and belts and like
all those things for it to really matter
they've got to go and be like okay clean
sweep wipe it out turn in all your
bounties and then you've got to be
you've everybody's got to start from the
same place if I'm working on Lunas how
cool I mean if you got to get up to
fabled and you grind that thing out that
is one piece of gear and if you spend
all your time grinding it out you're not
gonna get anything else at the time for
it so that like those type of quests
wouldn't matter but like having 20
bounties that give you powerful gear
that you're like hey let me get one
piece play a little bit let me turn into
another one so I can boost another piece
play a little bit because you know you
got sorry finish I'm sorry about you
saying that you are g on top of that
which is part of it which is it which is
okay but I mean orangey is a thing but
having 20 extra bounties to help you
fight orangey that's what yeah my thing
like I'm gonna keep it real like my new
thing now is I'm a week to the end of
the season and when the last iron banner
come and all I'm just gonna hold all the
engrams that's what that's the new thing
now that's the new digs if I want to be
well first forget the scale forget the
days I'm just gonna hold in grams not
caching man I'm gonna have the whole
Chris the whole tower going look like a
Christmas tree full of notifications
[Laughter]
[Music]
I've come out that I'm like yeah I'm
ready cash out you know me or whatever
season six cash out let's go and and
roll the dice up to the new level of 700
jeez this is what Bungie wants this is
what they telling me to do and no to
succeed I guess I gotta adapt but I mean
that's the wrong mentality example
exactly which you wrote they gotta fix
that like I'm not I'm not about that
mm-hmm
and that'd be one of those pieces where
it's like okay so your new content is
this at like six so you know 600 you
finish the quest like even to have 45
minutes killing random adds you're not
gonna get any light level from that and
then you send me into a quest or the
six-thirty first time and no second time
in probably worse third time I didn't
even see the boss like then I took some
even the people like I took you got me
who's in chat right now shout out to him
and then the other guy paired up with
from a plane with pyro like we paired up
we went in there the first two times we
didn't even see the boss and that same
earlier day I had seen the boss with
randoms I'm like I don't even know
what's happening so it still is not easy
by any means um we finally got our stuff
together and got it taken care of but
like no it's yeah that whole the
levelling up in this piece is gotta get
gotta get reviewed gotta get looked at
wiping the slates clean at Sur at like
you know new expansion reset it's a
thing it's got to be a thing so yeah I
mean I was testing a couple things as
well I hadn't turned into my malfeasance
quest and picked it up because I was
like I hadn't turned in chaperone for so
long because I was waiting for it to be
I didn't want it in the exotic loot pool
for Duke a smart mm-hmm I left that one
there and I was like well you know what
I'm close to it anyway I may as well
just leave it there and see what happens
mm-hm I logged in and I could pick up
that thing at 6:03 first thing I didn't
do it yet cuz it's still sitting there
at about six eleven so it's always above
so I'm just waiting for that to a point
room like they have finally I'll pick it
up but I don't need malfeasance enough
but I know if I pick it up it's gonna
help give me that boost when I'm
absolutely absolutely I mean all of so
like that's one gun to which is like
yeah it would help once yeah yeah mm-hmm
though it's like one piece here one
quest maybe but it's like the 25
bounties that's the part that's just
like brutal and those ones I'm like
those are the ones who are 650 like I
don't
there's no honest way to get there's no
normal way to get there not all the way
yeah there's no normal line exactly
yeah so yeah make unused bounties reset
every week like if you don't yeah make
them under reset every week or something
like that I mean turn them in and get
your gear get your level get your
whatever is gonna come from it because
that's what people are mmm yeah so
that's exactly what it is yeah people
are just taking too much stuff so
exactly
no dog lot we cleared that up yeah I
mean Bungie said it was on the fifth
literally they did it Wednesday they
said you know effective immediately this
is it now this is the piece I've never
seen them react as fast yeah so what do
you think of this it literally it drops
Tuesday and Wednesday night they'd
adjusted it what they could it's a
server side changed bringing everything
down five but what do you I mean what do
you think just the fact that their
reaction was that quick and what do you
think of the reaction as well um the the
reaction being that quick showed me tell
me two things it told me one they are
very sensitive to negative press because
the minute the word got out that black
armory was damn near unplayable
you know from for the majority in the
community that thing spread like
wildfire and that showed me that they do
have a temperature of what's going on
shout out the game before today and a
chat get a great point about this whole
thing but um yeah like it showed me like
I'm not you're right I've never seen the
reaction and I'm saying from them on
this quick but again you know it's a
shout out that somebody on Twitter had a
funny meme I don't know who it was it
was like a employee and it's like it has
his name and they said Bungie and it's
like yeah just I just gave him five it
was a funny meme but basically okay fine
you did something but you know I didn't
really feel that was substantial and
they even mentioned it as we're about to
read it that that wasn't that
substantial so you know at the end of
the day I'm glad it was acknowledged
right and I'm glad that when I read the
paragraph that they said look we
understand that this you know being
reduced by five on our server side level
is all we can do right now and that's
not enough when we wanted to do
something I appreciate the effort
you know saying we got that but at the
end of the day you know shout to your
boy vagabond and the chat is these
people who are gonna refuse to play this
content until something else happens you
know I'm saying because no one wants to
grind the old content so they still have
a ways to go but it's a two part thing
it was it was yes I'm gonna have to
happen I'm glad there was something but
no there has to be more but they also
show me there's a high level of
sensitivity towards the situations what
a negative press so what did you feel
about this whole situation we're done
with the UM the the update hmm
I mean the speed of it was good I mean
they listened but also the speed of it
means they didn't judge it right in the
first place if they have to make a snake
a knee-jerk reaction per se is something
that they didn't plan and think about
how their community would react and they
judged it wrong I mean that's one of
those hey we think the community is
gonna really like this thing okay either
the messaging around it was wrong mm-hmm
they didn't tell us what level these
things were gonna be hmm
and this is the first piece of gear we
get we get a quest we get 45 minutes and
then we're stuck like that play test
experience some ball had to be dropped
somewhere because if say I'm a developer
and I'm sitting there working you're
like hey go check out this dip you know
this run-through for black armor okay
we're gonna put you at 600 say
somebody's max 600 Luckett okay a
run-through do the quest to figure out
what's efficient go to the forge you
need to get match-made with some couple
people even if they're testers like a
couple time over it's like and if
somehow you like do that you see the
boss at half health I'm like so is this
this all we get to do or it's like I
can't finish this first activity like
mm-hmm
so I mean now maybe everyone in Bungie
is like a desti god cool if you guys are
but again remember like there's an
audience that follows me 27,000 people
are crazy enough to look at my videos
thank you all by the way I appreciate it
but for those of you guys who who do
those people are looking for like solo
grinds and help on more of a casual
scale and I'm not a destiny god what are
some tips on this like if you're not at
the insane level mm-hmm it's one of
those pieces that's like it's gonna be a
oddball experience to start and that's
why I was like why can't they why can't
they start it lower and that's why some
people's like where the difficulties
where's like blind well tier 1 tier 2
tier 3 Wayne and this is kind of the
same thing back to escalation protocol
how it started and you couldn't get
through I couldn't get through level 2
for forever on escalation protocol
because for that wizard was
just invincible like that too much
health and why did it always have to be
like out like starting at like 385 just
to get to you know the first part of the
activity and again if you let people
experience the first couple levels then
you ramp it up towards the end you're
like oh it's like okay this starts the
level up but you know I made it through
a few bosses got a feel for something it
had like half of the experience like
getting your foot in the experience
enough to know that it's something I
might actually enjoy
mm-hm if in having a reason to go grind
is different than I think this might be
cool but I don't know but puts a go try
it right first time I have to go do the
other stuff I have to go grind Oh gonzo
right let me ask you this and I want to
play devil's advocate right yeah what
about the argument and I heard this shot
as I says game of Forte's in a chat I
want to shout him out and I want to
shout out brat podcast cause weight loss
sovereign was in their podcast and he is
an on destiny player right so he laughs
at the lords he's like you guys are
crazy
you know you know this you know that you
guys complain about the games too casual
and now they made it hard and you guys
are complaining again and I said okay he
made a make some point so my question to
you is that is this their handling of
black armory a result of our pitching
and now is this an example of us of us
getting what we want or is it something
else is it like you know still a slight
misstep on how they've handled things in
the past what's your honest assessment
of it no there's like multiple things
going on in chat right now so I'm gonna
try and hit a ball go for it um like
first yeah it's a small it's a small
misstep because like the knee-jerk
reaction wouldn't be needed if it wasn't
somewhat in what they were going for but
I mean as gaming Forte said it's like
they do I did they didn't buy a new
content to play old content first mm-hmm
they didn't say hey you need to go hit
those challenges you need to level up a
little bit before you go do this and
then if you slap on suggested 610 and I
look at it and in my eyes I see 6/10
okay and for one I should remember okay
it's Bungie that's a lie but
man like if you're gonna say six ten
actually mean it'd be like hey maybe
it's like recommended six ten okay they
they got a judge accordingly the average
person who looks at a nightfall at five
forty is like all can I do it at five
thirty five like maybe okay you might
get smoked if your five thirty like
there's that level curve in there needs
to be a factor like Nate you should have
been you know six twenty maybe hmm or
make more making normal mode in a hard
mode and this is why I wish they could
have done something like that yes normal
mode when you start do that one at 600
605 610 and you could do that for like
each the next one could be a little bit
higher 605 16 615 and then the third one
the drubbs could even be a little higher
depending on how long people have had to
play because the third the first third
dropped pretty close together I think so
all those three could have had that and
then you start released in hard mode
getting some else something involved in
a hard mode where that starts it the
volunter goes back Oh hard mode for
d'Avola under drops at six thirty
and then the other ones 6:35 then the
other ones six forty and then Lorraine
six forty and that way you have this
progression to build through for those
who want to be like normal mode gets me
that's cool normal mode hey this is that
second one I can cried like normal on
the third okay I just finished normal a
third this is the hard one hey let's go
back to hard mode we got a little bit of
a change here this is gonna help me
progress this continual progression is
something they've really really really
got to work on in my opinion because for
me when I go and again I'm like chomping
down no I'm like Sean Finegan I talk
about World of Warcraft all the time
because it's just a point of reference
because even things like strikes seemed
like shoehorned in on the side of here's
this thing you can grind on but it's not
incorporated into the playthrough it's
not like hey you're gonna hit the soft
cap here up to 500 you want to go grind
some strikes hey grind some strikes play
if like you know four or five six twenty
of them however many that's gonna get
you up to five twenty five five thirty
okay then you do that Haven blind well
is gonna be dropping some gear that goes
from 5.30 to 550 then you can have stuff
that go start then the raid starts
getting you higher from there those
types of progressions to give you a
reason to run all of you think things in
the game is something I still wish this
game would do better yes yes it's the
scale indeed they still struggle with it
right they still you wanna
even when escalation protocol it was
still that
proceed the light levels and and getting
that point of entry and like like you
said it just comes down to you know you
have to be able to enter the new content
experience it and then it's a gradual
path to progression you know I'm saying
as opposed to this just brick wall like
almost like a bounce at the club line
you cannot get in and it's just like
whoa I just purchased this new content
like can I at least try it
No get back out there go do all that old
stuff didn't come back and talk to me
and it's like and then on top of it it's
not clear right there's no out shot I
believe it's um oh my god is Scott in
your chat like did they almost should
have also started to UM start that
leveling process the week before right
maybe give us that like that little gap
on on the power creep and get that going
right to give us a shot because if they
if they if they intend to keep it this
way they truly work hard and fast like
hey you know this is what its gonna be
it's gonna be this light in this light
all right boom you can now start the
creep and thought to get drops out in a
while and use those those are what's
those guys that you talked about the
guys that uh had the blue orbs and stuff
on them right saboteurs they yeah what
would have been dope is that last week
you dropped those guys in the wild you
beat those six over you start getting
powerful drops to prep you so now you're
getting it you're introducing a new
content with this cool you know these
cool little things almost like the the
wolves are howling back in the day
remember we used to find the wolves
howling and did you know you beat them
in its new content you're like wow
something cool has entered the world
you're all excited and then you get it
popping but to just do this like hard
and do like imma be honestly like as a
person who's just now gone from console
to PC and I'm at like like 5 20 whatever
right I'm sitting there like there is no
way I've not only got a grind of six
then when I get to six dad ain't even
enough right so my whole thing is when
we get into this 12 is I'm waiting to
Tuesday you're gonna see what I am not
touching it and
till Tuesday when they make those
adjustments that we're gonna talk about
and then I'm getting into it because for
me that's just me banging my head
against a brick wall that the drops are
not gonna be substantial enough for me
to make any impact on progression that's
the way it currently stands right now
yeah I mean yeah you're completely right
when we get to what they're changing
next week is gonna be definitely a
reason for you to wait I mean you can
play a little bit but you're not gonna
be like oh I'm gonna no life grind this
thing be like no I'm just gonna wait
because it's not gonna happen
mm-hmm but like a couple of people said
it in chat as well here's like the
factor of all these things coming
together oMG it's cool said you guys
think had they released the power up
level last week at the beginning of
season 5 there would've been no backlash
or how hard the forges but then in turn
what if they would have liked the
release that week before do you think
the raid would have been like a cakewalk
mmm it was like how do you balance
though all of those little inner working
pieces mm-hmm okay no if they would have
let you grind last week and this is
again where hard caps outside of raid
stuff would be a good idea as well right
all right all right we're getting like
you know have a higher soft cap be like
hey you got up to 6:10 well it's gonna
take you forge to get above that cuz you
know forge activities will limit it
there then later on other stuff can drop
like give you a reason why give you a
reason to go grind some of the new stuff
and then slowly like ease back up on
what's good and just open up more
activities as you go like they don't
start iron banner giving you all
powerful gear but then later on they
sure seem to open it up same idea right
right after though all of those types of
pieces would be really nice to say a
start here working on this and then more
and more things would help you get back
up to that level so mm-hm no I agree I
agree I agree I mean into me shot the
slow-mo nature hoop lens you wanted
y'all fighting through this all the way
to February you know what I feel like I
feel not that the content wasn't gonna
be substantially because we still don't
know what the content is we most of us
have not accessed it but it just feels
like an artificial time gaining and feel
like you're trying us
slow my hand you know don't rush it Joe
wait until you know that and then this
rate I am dying to see that what's gonna
happen today I'm very curious when that
raid goes live I'm dying to know the
when the statistics come out on world's
first how many how long on PC how long
on console I am dying to know these
numbers it to me is gonna be very
interesting yeah I'm trying to pull up
dusty tracker right now so I could
actually see it I don't even know what's
still there but just to see how many
people are max level is more my
curiosity let me see if I can look light
level so you got 650 s 649 648 642 s and
that's I don't know how many there's 84
people and that's like 640 so I'm gonna
kind of look through and see how many
might be there but like I mean just the
fact that people are 650 and as Huseyin
in check yeah oMG is saying and Chad
he's like I play I'm playing six hours a
night since drop of this week and he's
only six oh seven
he's like a terrible terrible drops and
stuff like that but he played it real
yeah I guess if I had to guess that oMG
is that you were playing through like
you didn't save up any bounties you
jumped in normally or done uni worked on
your daily challenges worked on your
weekly challenges you've got you know
you're dreaming city that you'll
probably get to a little bit later and
even if you did knock out the radon
multiple characters you might be like
612 if you like did everything and had
pretty solid on G and that rate is 640
mm-hmm and that's kind of the idea of
like this whole curve balance of power
and everything is gonna be and it's they
don't want the raids to be easy they
don't want these four just to be easy
because soon as we're like 650 those
forges are gonna be easy and that's why
a hard mode is not a bad idea as right
give it an extra mechanic give it
something higher like 640 is that piece
that's a great point like I just feel
his mode and stuff like they used to do
back in the day you know yeah even the
stuff like I don't know why they've gone
away from that mentality because it
again but it's like what they and you
say like with once you good of light
with blazing
anyway so it's just you're just trying
to hold the inevitable again I'm not
trying to make it this easy point of
entry so that everyone blazes all the
content there has to be some difficulty
but what I'm saying is just like this is
so staunch this is so you know that
there can be a better way they they
still have to figure that out there's
there and I think what you said is is
all the money with like a hard mode I
think you definitely on to something
with that mm-hmm yep so I'm just trying
just trying to keep up with chat right
now scenery a chat late right now I know
chat both chats al it right now you shot
the addict he said he'd make me play
more for the same result so by the time
you get to where you finish this the
next one drop yeah it sort of in my
opinion artificial time getting you know
and and they've got to do a better job
at that that DAC cannot this dis cannot
be the way you know saying again
forsaken they figured out a lot of good
things now they weren't there go in a
new approach I get it they're going with
you know endgame content annual pass
more things to you know to try to shoot
for and they said this was not gonna be
the traditional campaign and stuff you
know I'm saying you know traffic I got
it he's like give us better stuff the
ground for their stuff the graph what a
problem is no one can access it to even
attempt to crack it yeah that's the big
so you know yeah alright so no it's like
so this week at Bungie dropped last
night's finally got a chance to read it
pretty late but obviously the black door
armory opened its doors quick old quest
happened you know and they did change
the power level they did that really
quick so this is where your piece first
comes in mm-hmm
because were many of you are still
increasing your power to attempt a new
challenge yesterday we lowered the power
requirement of law storage by five this
wasn't huge fortunes are meant to be
aspirational extensions of the endgame
but we did want to make them more
accessible to guardians around six
hundred power so I change happen this is
your big one yeah for some of you the
enemies guarding the enemies guarding
the loss words are immune to your
weapons we promised more details for
players who are still working up to six
hundred and beyond
here's what we have planned six hundred
power mmm prime engrams will now drop
more frequently and with larger power
bumps for players under six hundred so
all the way up to six hundred this is a
two day change and this is
gonna happen Tuesday whose day got heard
that y'all Tuesday's when I'm back
hardcore seriously continue yeah so I
mean the changes planned for Tuesday
they're also considering additional
changes to assist with the power climb
in the future they'll continue to
monitor feedback I'm like if you even
bump up the Blues like I mean come on
somebody leveling up at this point just
still waiting on priming grams from five
hundred to five hundred from five
hundred all the way up I'm sorry
take that soft cap bump that to five
fifty because it's still not gonna hurt
that much and they want to get into some
of the new stuff if this is the
aspirational things I mean still you're
gonna be grinding night falls and things
like that and if he wants the hundred
thousand score you still gotta get to
six hundred the rate is basically five
ninety get you at least get those Blues
up to five fifty make some of that stuff
be more accessible come on now so I mean
that soft cap needs a bit of a bump and
hopefully they look at that too cuz
anybody else who jumps in like feel like
hey you want to try forsaken it's like I
mean at this point for me somebody could
be like hey it's black arm I should be
getting the annual pass I'm like I don't
know what to say because for one I've
only touched one piece of it so it's a
heart judge but it was like six months
or now I may be like oh there's so much
content in here it's awesome the grind
is really cool the leveling off is fun
awesome right now I would be like if
you've played up to forsaken and you're
just waiting on the annual pass to see
do you love the duel of Destiny cool it
is gonna be more destiny you're gonna be
doing more of the grind if you love it
right if you you know if you're new to
the game just go play Forsaken and have
fun in that like for second I'm an
amazing grind like if you're new if you
are new and you get that boost like in
you're playing through the campaign and
for sake and dreaming city and all that
stuff is like that stuff is awesome and
then you gradually work up to 600 maybe
by then they have some of these like
adjustments fixed but it's like right
now it's just like yeah play forsaken
enjoy that as opposed to worrying so
much about the annual pass cuz it's hard
to tell somebody spend 35 bucks when
right now you got one piece of content
if you're not are you max level that's
what I mean if I have to ask a question
it's kind of a hard turn around so there
are some adjustments that need made for
sure I mean listen this is nice this is
cool
you know I like that baffling rims are
gonna you know give you more but like
you said the soft cap has to go up I'm
curious to know they say you know
they're supposedly they also the
sentence is we are also considering
additional changes to assist with the
power can climb in the future update so
that's what I want to know I want to
know what that's gonna because the
priming grams are cool you know also how
much of a bump
all these priming grams gonna give you
know I'm saying if it is it gonna be
like a you know 20 light level joy is it
you know 510 like what what is it what
it what does that mean right now it's
about 5 to 10 depending on how far you
are cuz when I've had a primary gram the
drop did six oh six when I was like 601
and I had one when I was like 605 drop
it like 612 so I've had like six seven
eight somewhere in there my my brother
got one that was like 609 he had a huge
jump
but like less than 10 for sure yeah it
was like 3 to 5 except those random
sporadic ones that'll give you a little
boost but I mean is it 10 levels is it
15 like is it a little bit more because
it's still just one drop and if you're
going on you got a prime in gram you got
a 15 point boost
that's one slot and what if your next
prime ingredient you're like well crap
so they got a they got to make them
pretty frequent and if they're and it's
a balance of like frequency to make the
grind like kind of worth it
mm-hmm versus like you know 20 points a
pop and everything being magical so when
there's a little bit of a grind in there
so the people playing through still got
to do some leveling up but I mean they
want to get to the new content give them
a little long to get there I mean don't
you it from a business standpoint you
want to promote your new content you
want people to get inside this you know
dang and start experiencing it and you
want them to buy that in you'll pass you
don't say there's people now that's like
I'm not gonna touch that like for what
like if I can't even do anything right
I'll wait until you guys tell me it's
safe to get in there you know zip and
that's it you know so oh yeah I was like
weird looking up to see how this
progresses like right now a lot of
things are up in the air I don't think
it started right I think they could have
handled things differently so that's
just my opinion even my buddy was like
is even like one of my buddies and my
brother were like do you ever not like
this game is that do they ever do
anything wrong
I think because they give me the whole
Bungie their destiny shale moment yeah
and I was honestly do you think this ad
was like no honestly don't know yeah so
it's just one of those pieces it's a
weird it's it's a new model and this is
where we're gonna kind of get to the
other side of it or at least I can say
right now so what they're trying to do
with this is always have something kind
of new for us going on as opposed to the
other side of this when we have the
giant content drought so what is your
trade off in what you like what was it
was taking King was basically a huge
content drought because we never really
got expansions from that did we right
right now it is so like we got taken
King we leveled up and it was just like
okay what you still didn't play in this
game right like there wasn't that much
purpose so now you basically have a
taking king moment which was like
forsaken that turn around and then you
have stuff like this that they're gonna
try and trickle out and that's what
they're really we're going for is on
just like giving us something like
here's this this week and the next week
next week in the next week and they're
trying to do like weeks and weeks of
content then the next season of The
Drifter which is gonna be a different
piece you're still gonna level up to 700
in there so there's gonna be a lot of
game but I guess I don't know or just
more grinding of the same but it's like
if you still love that dusty grind and
still just doing those activities some
of the things about the season past that
hurt me though was like yeah all that
stuff could be coming but it's like in
some of those expansions we got strikes
we didn't get anything this is like the
closest probably I can think is black
armor or not black armor is taken King
because we really didn't get new strikes
we got that like one
I think strike which was like a reverse
mission right um and that was later
anyway like April we got one so it's
like this that that's kind of a
comparison to think of so they are
trying to give us a lot of stuff
throughout the year
mm-hmm but it's just a weird feel of
like waiting for okay so if I play the
black armor it's like okay so if I get
up to 650 by you know January 18th when
niobe labs comes out is that just an
experience I want to go do or maybe I'm
getting ready for some else what do you
feel I think that listen I really don't
have a problem with
what so far is being offered in black
armory it's just the way it's handled
because let's be real
I mean this we're still getting a ready
today right green is dropping a day the
problem wada community is so frustrated
and so down is point of entry
so if point of entry was a little bit
better right
Natick he made a good point he said I'm
gonna give them a pass on this cuz it's
clearly of clays case of how much do you
wanna grind
oh not that much gotcha it's literally
that it's like to me they went soul on
the air of caution right they were like
we heard you d2 we're vanilla was too
easy right
so black army Trump's and again brick
wall now they're like oh wow you guys
don't like it that hard okay cool
will will will tweak it will treat so I
think what it is this is them being
extremely conservative I'm saying if
they tweak it cuz at the end of the day
when it comes down to your question
which is the content I think from what
we've seen and I've seen through other
piece it looks really cool and then we
like I said I'm dying and know what this
raid is about and and again this is not
a raid lair
right this is a raid domain so again I
want to see what that's about then you
got the next for this thinks has the
potential to really be good it's just a
shame no one could really express I
don't want to really trash black armory
yet cuz really none of us knows what
black armory truly is based on
accessibility yep yeah I mean that's
kind of the biggest thing you said it
right like the content in the next few
weeks on that calendar like I forgot the
other for dropping today at the same
time as the raid so people are gonna be
rating sometimes we're gonna try the new
forge then like next I think it's the
18th if I remember right for the next
one and you got niobe labs in January so
you got those for spread out Christmas
people are gonna travel they're not
gonna punch push a whole lot out then
and that's right mm-hmm
and it's those pieces that are like it's
set up to have you always having kind of
new stuff to do it's like you know as
you level up in your grind up to 600 if
you're a normal level player and I'm 600
and I'm like hey I'm gonna get like 608
this week cool then that new one drops
as long as
doesn't hit me in the face with like 650
I'm like oh my god again so it's like if
they space those out and have the levels
of each activity for like a higher than
average player but not like the god tier
because you can't base everything off
God to hear that something division
screwed up on yeah absolutely but if
you're on like higher than average so
somebody who's like hey I play like an
hour a night yeah you're probably gonna
not gonna get there as quickly but if
you play like you know a couple hours a
night or something like that or you play
like a decent amount during the week you
should feel somewhat close to be ready
for each activity if they space that out
right and it feels pretty good as your
progression of like hey I'm working up
to 650 every week I'm up to like 620
right now all the new Ford shop it's
like 635 okay there's gonna be a bit of
challenge let's work through and then as
you go even if you don't raid that
progression of these other activities
are something you can match make in to
which is why matchmaking is a key right
matchmaking if people are dumb is hard
if you're playing with a made team it's
not gonna be as bad but if you
matchmaking to those things just realize
those match made people could be trying
that stuff at even worse level exactly
just that that scaling of everything if
they can manage that it could be really
cool as you set the rate is today - I
want to know how big this is yeah I want
to sculpt I'm seeing cool things I'm
keep seeing people on sparrows and girls
are definitely a thing they even
mentioned it we'll get to it well we can
do that right now let's do it so the
trailer little teaser is up you guys and
watch it it's about 30 seconds so I'm
not gonna play the video on here for you
guys but it is cooling trailer it's I
mean it's in that city this is like a
really really cool location so we've got
the lost city out there the trailer
stuff and so design lead Brian Frank
he's one of the new raid guys you want
to kind of spill the beans on all the
stuff we got going on with the raid oh
yeah I mean pretty much it's you know
very much is going up today and then he
ca said the team couldn't be more
excited you know I'm saying so they want
to fight you gonna fight your way
through the last city recover a
forgotten secret of the black armory you
know as always they're gonna be getting
a cheer on they don't even do the
world's first rate belt jackets you know
saying all the flat stuff that we all
love and it says anyone who beats it
you know the counters the 20 what a
disgorge of nothing
and they said so basically we got was at
9 a.m. Pacific on the 12th to beat the
raid claim your cold purchased a jacket
on the Bundy store and obviously if you
scroll down you get to see that fly miss
them and any championship belt which
looks clean can I fly man at a jacket
and the belt look very very clean almost
a flight jacket kind of feel you know
from the 90s and um the whole
championship felt like a little WWF like
this is a cool touch man and again all
this stuff we just want to know what
it's about you know say so at the end of
the day the stuff looks cool you know we
want to see what what goes wrong way but
uh what did you feel you know reading
this kind of thing they giving you know
um scourge of the past the same kind of
treatment that they gave a last wish
yeah I mean this is kind of their way to
do rate releases now and they did say I
mean this is a new rate it's not a rate
layer so but I mean basically every raid
experience for them they want it to be a
big deal because the raid team has a lot
of fun and these are some of the best
pieces of content and destinies so they
do want to hype it up they want you know
twitch they'll be watching this stuff
they're gonna have you know the race is
going on and the rewards are cool it's
like the you know the emblem looks sick
there's only a short number of people
who get that one in the first 24 hours
shout-out to dad oh sorry
eggs but it's like you got the jacket
you got the belt and these are was just
really cool it's just a way to hype up
your player base I mean this thing is
probably not like crazy quality but
bunchy usually doesn't slouch and as
much as people put into this they can go
pretty good and like you have to buy the
jacket anyway so I mean they're not
really losing their so I mean it's it's
cool stuff for people who want to like
put the time in and no life hitting the
esoterics and the t-rex is who have been
literally living this game for three
days hmm and they're gonna get to that
point where like sweet we're gonna go
into the raid I'm just hoping the rain
is like not beat in a couple hours
yeah lucky for them yeah good I'm sorry
just for the people who got to 650 which
is exactly what you're about to say
probably no I will actually go I'm just
curious how many encounters are gonna be
yeah that's true cuz they mean they said
it was not last wish but crota as well
see I was pictured crotas not like you
could blow through it quickly but when
you had to learn the encounters you had
the you know you had the abyss
you had the bridge you had the little
walkway wasn't actually that bad just
took a little bit to figure out and but
then you had the wizard and then you had
curly you still have four encounters in
there right right so it wasn't that they
same it's big in a crota but what I mean
last wish was like basically six if you
consider the heart because you have leg
you know those three of Morgoth you have
the vault and then after the vault it
goes to ribbon so and then you have the
heart so in a sense you have like six
overall kind of checkpoint encounters
yeah so I mean four to six like yeah but
I I don't know if they're considering
crota to be more like three and maybe
this one has four I don't picture it
having more than four
that's my exist me too I'm which I think
it's gonna be like four encounters
yeah three and a half or maybe three I
mean three or four somewhere in there
but it's not like a jumping puzzle on a
boss it's gonna be more than that
how much did a rat's machine have cuz we
had the first one we you know just to
get in there though dodgeballs then we
had the second encounter which is kind
of like was it the cable guy already
we called the cable guy would always
stop coming in up down in cuz yeah you
go up you jump up really high and you
had kind of a long jumping puzzle you'd
go through for like all Rab air ducting
up top the secret chest and then I feel
like you would jump down in and fight
him back to back right back back and
down then it was the siege engine you
know right so that's three and then axis
had access to phases so will you see
encounters it's busy for encounters but
you know phases on on the last one so
like if they gave ratted a machine
length you know like yeah I would say it
I think Adams teasing you about a crota
saying it was three and a half I guess
you you've not agreeing I don't know I
mean well it's like it depends on what
you consider like if you consider the
final area of like though of the wizard
part before curtain like it's all in the
same space but you consider that a full
encounter in itself is that like just
part of the room and something like it's
a you can do for you can do three
whatever I'm just saying like it'll
depend
you classified I don't know how they
classified on their and is it like per
space is that like what they consider or
what so that's all I was gonna say good
question um what else we got
so yeah rate is dropping watch out on
twitch see the crazy people who grinded
their lives out hopefully crush this
thing but hopefully not too quickly I'll
be curious if it's like if the last boss
is like 6 exe and it's just always hard
and they go back they haven't done that
in a while so I don't think they will so
I think it's gonna max at 650 so kind of
curious to see like what the Sparrow
racing part of it is because there's
definitely see Sparrow driving because
they mention it where do they mention it
I know I read it mm-hmm
they say get your uh maybe it's towards
the end they say get your Sparrow
collections ready because you're gonna
need them for perks and things like that
I'm like what is happening laughter
data's yeah that was cool baby oh sects
of escape I don't know I just sounds
like you just driving through the city
cool sparrows I'm dying to see how this
mechanics gonna work as well as the
encounter so I'm definitely gonna be
keeping my eye on on this on this raid
in people's progression yeah so that'll
be watching later today which will be
like literally zur the new forge and
that go live at the same time so it's
gonna be a little crazy so oh yeah kind
of a curious observer has anything that
changes so that's what I'll be checking
come 11:00 a.m. mm-hmm
oh but let's see so crucible next big
topic so they said they want to address
some feedback and crucible they have
report they know the top issue is the
Saudis associated with matchmaking
especially in competitive as well also
they've expressed feedback about solos
against fire teams glory hot like high
glory teams verse low glory teams they
are working on all of that they don't
have a whole lot to say on that at that
point but they definitely know that is a
high point of contention for a lot of
people so it is definitely something
they said the appropriate teams are
investigating changes and the let us
know is you know in a future update as
soon as they can so they don't have an
answer right now but they want us to
know that they're not ignoring us on
matchmaking they're considering it I
mean this is a bungees thing they're
gonna evaluate everything above ground
which they do because they don't want to
make like rash decisions but in turn
it's one of those things at least it's
an acknowledgement they're looking at it
like probably one of the first time so
that's a good piece they do have some
information on changes coming power and
most bonds is a big one for a lot
because even you and I were playing here
like how does he already have power in
moment starts mmm Mike if I swear the
first spawn is so like the first one is
partially an issue but in staffed for
that it's gonna be like noticeably
different in a lot of pieces but for
competitive power mo is a huge factor I
mean used to be like we didn't have
competitive we had trials like we had
all our playlists we have trials was
kind of like competitiveness everybody
pictures that as being like you had the
one round of competitive now heavies
everywhere so that's gonna be a thing so
this will be good yeah we've got
actually I mean your the crucible man
you know I mean pretty much it like you
said it you know this is some major
heavy ammo economy changing so they
basically a lot of this is coming down
basically down to the timers you got
competitive we got control so pretty
much what's consistent with all this is
the initial timers of when they spawn
will stay the same but then it says all
increase respawn timer you know I'm
saying for heavy ammo so now goes from
in control for 45 to 120 in clash you
know the same 45 to 120 survival it goes
from 45 to 60 then you got the rotators
which show down you know thirty to sixty
and then from Rumble also 60 to 120 so
that's that's pretty cool they didn't
also talking about arm power Matt power
and one matchmaking are not the only top
trending pieces of community feedback
that they have been tracking many of you
have sandbox related questions and they
said a vocal camps on both sides and
reference to what apply to pvp and PVE
so they've taken a whole bunch of that
data with that and this is what I liked
which is these next two paragraphs which
is our lead design I believe it was dawn
john sandwich as a funny man and also it
seems making fun of Hamrick always make
a hamburger I'm like why these now
you've never understand what its Hamrick
okay let me scroll down yeah so um
basically this is the part where I got
excited which he's like okay many people
you know talk about how you know the
frequency in decadence you know of how
the passion comes out so he says we got
some hot questions coming up I just
wanted to take a second to call
something you may have noticed instead
of building up to one or two massive
patches a year we have transition to
shipping smaller batches of changes much
more frequently we hope that this new
approach will allow us to remain more
agile than we've been in the past allow
us to shake up the meta a bit more
frequent interview of intervals we hope
that a year from now we can look back on
this new way of work and agree that it
was very successful alright enough of my
rambling and he's gonna go on to the
questions now before we get into the
questions these are some really good
questions that I want to touch about I
want to talk about that paragraph and I
want to know like how you felt when you
read it in reference to sandbox cadence
I mean it's been something we've asked
for for how many years
oh that's basically it like I mean
everybody wants these changes to be
faster more frequent they need Bunji
needs to be more nimble with changes
being able to update things when things
are broken the same sandbox for six
months gets old I mean what we always
want is like throw changes out there if
things are a little broken we know
there's gonna be another passage changes
it because you can't change it quickly
but if we know we get one sandbox change
it all comes in auto rifles get a point
zero seven percent damage buff and it's
like if you get one of those and you're
just like or stuck for another six
months I mean yeah please against that I
mean it's like they're going from it's
like develop software development
methodologies from like waterfall to
agile literally said agile in there
you're like you're not setting up for
this one giant launch and everything has
to be why but waiting on that hey you
get a three week sprint you launch it
out in that month and legit they'll do
another one like as quick as I can on
the better yeah absolutely this is only
a good thing to me huge huge because
again I'm with you man like the key with
this is this what makes the game fresh
and for them to wait so long and this is
one bit like let's get that I frequency
up let's add these changes and again
even if it's just on a small level to
test them out and then you know you make
adjustments as you go on to something
instead of hard and fast nerves I'm cool
with that too you know I'm saying like
this is what I need to see for them
because that makes the meta exciting but
now we're gonna get into these questions
that he's talking about so the first
question he's like
can you buff snipers we would really
like French to be reduced and to have
more lower zoom scopes so he says
snipers are definitely one of the
archetypes we are actively looking at
and making changes to for example ladle
later in January rapid-fire snipers will
be moving to a two shot body kill
additionally we're allowing considering
allowing more snipers to do to one-shot
supers on headshots in a future patch
lower zoom scopes exist in the game but
not have been particularly prevalent
with post forsaken weapons ie you know
it's just the primacy has been limited
to but they'll be increasing the number
of them in the game as we move forward
we don't currently have plans to alter
sniper French anymore at this time but
we will continue to keep an eye on your
feedback
you bought us what is your feeling on
snipers and this can these comments okay
so snipers and that's near a weird weird
thing I know we have space magic I know
everybody wants to be able to do like a
360 noscope it's a sniper rifle first
off I was like I'm just gonna flat out
say it how does a sniper rifle work it's
not like you can take a hundred meter
like a 200 meter shot while flying
through the air while being pelted first
you're gonna miss like the whole flinch
while zooming oh you want to look down
sights get shot in the soul the shoulder
and still be accurate
I'm sorry I'm glad I'm not touching that
preach lowers ooh that's okay cuz
honestly that helps just the way the
maps are built and that's like a whole
different issue we don't have a whole
lot of maps built for long range like
sight lines we got one kind of Nell but
we don't have that many so it's a point
where for one give us some maps that
give us a little more space to work with
hey let's not be a thing like make a map
out there word is like almost a sniper
game like throw some of that stuff in
there were you about to agree I could
think of one is like can conversions
that all I think is called convergence
the one that's that old deep do you one
map it's very long and then a semi long
halt like the two months at long
hallways yeah
that's what I'm talking about that's one
and then the second one is on Timmy it's
it's the trials of the nine bluish thing
board where it's like yeah yeah it's
very open but it's a geometry yeah yes
ish so yeah I mean I mean it's I mean
what I mean if somebody tells me it's
like how's the sniper work like you want
to be able to spin around a noscope I'm
no I'm not saying the like a good sniper
makes this makes it it makes it as
though I'm screaming hey screaming you
can do it more power to you by all means
knocking are you and that's kind of 360
like you know I say 360 no-scope but
even just ain't no scope with a sniper
always seemed like conceptually weird to
me yeah if you point a big gun at
somebody and you hit him in the chest
even if you don't aim yeah you're gonna
hurt him no but just the fact of what
some people can do is crazy the whole
drag scoping is weird and all that stuff
is like that and that's just always been
me
I mean destiny is gonna have its own
feel of guns and that's for sure how
they go but the whole drag scoping and
all that stuff and the flinch has just
been one of those pieces to eat and
again I may get slandered for this one
but that's just my opinion so like a
sniper should work like a sniper like I
mean camping is one thing but that's
literally what a sniper does you set up
as you like you hold down a port like
that's what it is yes I'm with you man I
think this is this is dope I mean I
actually like the two points I like is
actually rapid-fire sniper because I
feel that archetype is always
underutilized everyone wants to go with
the heavy impact you know I'm saying so
to see rapid-fire snipers move to a two
shot body kill that's dope that's gonna
encourage usage in the archetype so I
like that and then the second thing is
I'm which you man I per flinch gotta
exist well you are a sniper like if I'm
shooting you in the face and you're you
got your face in a scope you should not
be able to react so quickly to be able
to gun me down yeah I'm saying so I'm
cool with with the other thing the
rapid-fire snipe and all that stuff but
leave flinch alone do not get cuz then
it's gonna get crazy cuz that's people
just disregarding you know that means
you have the advantage on someone
camping
but it doesn't matter yes they're like I
don't know about that anymore
oh no but Worf here we go I got a side
you have an oval bar oh no it's been
broken you
there's no Villar super it claims to be
due to dominate right now and we're
planning to tweak it it's currently
slated Larry let me stop being let's not
be like that
it's currently slated to VLAN with a
banjo he'll fight for this one it
doesn't have a real talk it's ridiculous
it's ridiculous so I admitted it when I
first played you know D too literally
when I unlocked that subclass I'm like I
feel like I'm cheating like this is just
too much I am getting people to walls
shout to scream he was Nova walking with
me we do it oh my god if you guys had
two of them in there
wow I thought I had my Walkman that's I
gotta get my son my subclass see before
this thing gets nerfed but uh yeah it's
really dominant to charge up the radius
you know I actually know my thing is
it's the length I think the length is a
little too long because I've literally
wiped the whole squad and still roaming
around looking for me yeah it's
ridiculous it's ridiculous
my hope is length you know um I don't
know if they're gonna touch radius if
they touch radius maybe and I'm saying
what you know it is what is that that's
coming so let's get into more spread
spectral blades hit detection feels much
more consistent can sensible and other
melees get the same treatment their
answer we definitely want all melee
supers to feel as good and reliable as
possible this is something we are still
looking into and this is the next one
which I know you smiled when you read
this hey how long ago did I call this
nearly oh they're totally read it I get
to really cuz I get to eat crow and he
gets to throw it in my face right now
so a lot of the pre forsaken subclasses
feel underpowered now
go ahead and continue you love it this
you love it me read this a lot of the
priest was taking sunglasses feel
underpowered
can they get buffed Bunji yes we have
some plan buffs coming to older subclass
pass in the patch currently slated for
late January bori already looking ahead
to what we like to do in patches future
down the line further down the line will
be regular looking into tuning subclass
content to ensure there's a healthy
balance of viable choices in all
activities we use a combination of data
and community feedback aka braches
pitching to track the right things to
fit the fix so please continue to
surface which choices feel the least
viable to help guide us all right the
floor is yours this is your moment I
gotta hear it let me go get my drink now
you already said it does it like I
caught this like weeks ago cuz just the
feeling of the supers
you've got Goku you've got like all
these other things and you're like how
many of you guys go use like okay yeah
how was the last time you use a nova
bomb all of those things I'm sorry but
like spectral blades makes Golden Gun
look like a joke yeah yeah it just did
dominate so yeah they are I mean they
made them great yeah so that's kind of
one of those pieces it's like yeah they
need to they need to get the others they
need to have more viable options and the
other piece too is like the perk trees
like you think about something that
where things are like so they work
together really really well they're like
so synergistic and even just the tweaks
to like the void grenades for the
Sentinel how those things can chain
together like certain things work
together in their little perk trees so
much better
who screams like I used a Golden Gun
yesterday on accident leg it's just one
of those it's just it's yeah it's crazy
so I'm happy to be on as much as I'm you
know laughing at you being right and we
were wrong it needed to happen this is
what you want you want you want
everything to be fine
what things to feel good you know say I
want it to be honest my main thing as a
warlock is I don't really feel the need
to use solar at all like I don't really
feel you to be a door blade right now
just how good Nova warp is you know I'm
saying even arm you know what you call
it um start the McKay are each being
changed up a bit it's actually a little
bit more viable now without turning off
the super quick and stuff like that so
I'm really in this thing and shout out
to um knocking what are you gonna use
like tickle fingers tickle fingers yeah
it's just not powerful enough you know
say just you know so in the I feel like
the length is too short there's a lot
that need to happen so yeah I'm which
honest so next question um in changes to
the - any changes to the top execs being
used in the crucible like a one-eyed
mask hey I just got this thing I'm gonna
get to enjoy it for like two weeks then
it's gone but yeah I actually did just
get it salute shards of gallon oil etc
Bungie these exotics get talked about
quite a bit and while I don't have any
immediate income and changes to share I
expected they will be getting looked at
in the future then the next this is
gonna affect me to less still
competitive - yeah oh yeah Telesto is
currently best oh can you tone it down
I'll move it to the power slot late in
January Bungie you'll find that Telesto
Smoltz to kill will now match its charge
rate where it was previously doing more
damage than any other than other fusion
rifles of its type that said due to its
being affected less by damage fall-off
due to its explosive nature it will
still be more consistent in fusion
rifles of the same charge rate worth
noting PvE damage will be increased to
keep parity there once we see how these
changes land we can decide if and what
we do next the goal is still being too
buff where we can and when we have to
nerf you're going to find us trying to
inch down instead of going nuclear
at least as much as we can so what do
you feel about Telesto in this I mean I
haven't faced it that much but I've
definitely seen like you know videos and
things that is just a monster and
especially competitive right now it's
like you're at a disadvantage not to use
it and that's the point where it needs
to get back to having other viable
options they want
it's like some people will say it's like
hey we know there's gonna be a meta
that's when things are good some people
love like the shotgun thorne meta
because like that was the top guns they
are still always trying to go to giving
more options but they are also they also
aren't nerfing stuff into the ground
like Telesto I don't think it belongs in
a power slot because you do give away
something like a machine gun or a rocket
launcher and especially in a PDE slot
you'd completely ruin the use of the gun
in PVE pvp if it's a fusion rifle if
it's a little more on track you got to
hit a few more your bolts you can't
cross map them with like four I mean you
can still shoot him on the ground you're
giving up an exotic to use this thing so
some benefits come there but I mean just
the fact they're going inches instead of
nuclear that's probably the best line of
all of it yeah that was a really cool
line I actually like that and as it's
I'm a Telesto user and I don't obviously
that was my cheesy loadout Loki in on
xbox I would literally um close it I was
running the Nazareth sing and I had so
basically void kills would increase
super recharge rate I had Telesto and
the ranges I would kill people with
Telesto is very beasty and I like act
this is a fair nerf tool éstos boast to
kill now matching the charge right
that's a key line because what what
happens even if you have charged you can
still get that kill off so now if I have
to really charge all the way to max in
order to get that max damage that's a
fair trade-off I feel that's there so
it's curious to see how that swing land
I liked it there buffing it in PvE
I think that's that's dope you know I
sense right oh yeah yeah so on to making
make it more viable but you know I'm
saying that because as it's currently
stayed it's like just more of a PvP
weapon so I'm and looks like they're not
even address the question about the
power slot moving so that I don't think
I should move there and it's still I
mean sleeper yeah that's a power weapon
right though it's still not that big
yeah so now we got the next two we got
Scott was like I've literally said this
one straight you're like PC how are they
I'm like they still suck
yeah no but I mean I've been good with
them but maybe I just again is what you
say okay okay PvE for sure cuz I can
stuff with my pulse rifle better than I
ever can
like a scout it just Hills Scouts feel
just typically feel a little bit weak
like Agron a little buff somewhere they
just I can't don't think they can keep
up
holsters do the same thing pulses
because you kills the Tama kill seems so
much faster there's any sort of exciting
is next question on scout rifle still
feel weak in both pvp and PVE can they
come up bungee this is another archetype
we're looking at and I would kind of
expect to see changes show up in future
patches Ken's SMGs to get a
non-precision damage buff
we just recently buffed the range on
smg's to make them more competitive
we'll be monitoring the data and
feedback for a bit to help us decide
where to take them next if we find that
they still aren't good enough we'll be
happy to buff them further and then
third question confusion rifles get
buffed maybe longer range or higher
damage to combat shotguns Bungie this is
another archetype we're looking at and I
will currently expect to see changes
show up in future patches we did bring
up the damage of rapid-fire fusion
fibrils rifles and two point one point O
so what do you feel about Scouts SMGs
and fusions
I mean Scouts need love I don't even
touch them basically they just sit in my
vault if I even pull one out it just
feels there was one I pulled out just
because again of course is your leveling
up I'll use of my higher stuff for now
but I'm just using it just doesn't it
doesn't feel right it doesn't feel great
I mean nameless midnight was great in
year one it was so good like felt good I
lived on that gun and now I don't I'm
like that tells you something's wrong so
yeah please Essen jeez I don't I don't
use them I really couldn't honestly tell
you the thing about these because I just
don't use them I mean if the range is a
little better maybe they're an option
but I don't to say have to dig through
and see but I mean if you through like
an Icarus grip if you had like a hipfire
grip on one and then maybe something
with like opening shot or stability
something like maybe it could be cool
but honestly that beat me trying out a
completely different place I which
doesn't feel like me but as people are
asking maybe it's something that needs
done because that's a that's not my
wheelhouse do you use them yeah I've
tried I used to be a big SMG guy 900rpm
some of the 600 so I used to use um was
my baby on the
rose burden I was a big SMG guy but the
problem now is now that s shotguns have
been reintroduced with the rolls and
everything excuse me
what has happened is you can't stop a
shotgun ape unless you have another
shotgun but that's it like if someone is
closing the distance and doing the slide
or jump towards you with that
Mindbenders ambition or that you know
dust rock blues or what's the other one
you know a chaperone retail hotel if
doeshot doeshot guns come up unless
you're not escaping and the ranges
people are having they using that um
well shot the fallout place got the
great video on it you know I'm saying
that rifle door full choke yeah you know
exactly everybody's running it if you
have if you're lucky enough to get one
of them roles you're not if you have an
SMG if you have you know a sidearm
they're laughing at you they're gonna
they're gonna eat all those bullets and
run you down it's not gonna work so
something has to do they have to do
something like few shot the bone he said
fusions have nothing on shot ease no
more now I grew see that was my counter
my counter was tell us though cuz what I
would do is I just be backing up as soon
as I see I'm backpedaling Charlotte boom
I got you I would make sure I keep my
just not granted if we both heard the
corner and he sees me I'm done you know
saying like there's no reaction I'll
take that loss but as long as I keep
backpedaling I got enough if I backpedal
with an SMG they're gonna they're gonna
eat all that smack me up it'll be honest
so smg's need to be adjusted in this
matter in my opinion so that's what I
got and then um any plans to adjust wave
splitter not the top of our list but we
do intend to take a look at it first we
want to take a look at the global
economy off for trace rivals in PvP and
then we can take a look at lives but is
affected this might as well as the P a
PlayStation 4 yeah or it's the void link
the void trace rifle yeah which even so
I was like shadow two markers on here a
little while back he loves that gun yeah
I heard his piece no I haven't I haven't
touched it I don't know yet the people
that have it and I shout the ass to
quote I've heard some nasty things
that's his favorite shots across low
it's nasty it's nasty man so you got
that all tightness gating is rampant on
PC do you plan to remove it
Bunji we like to fix it however we're
being careful about how we do this
because it's so closely tied to the core
feel of the lift ability in other words
we don't want to tight it up want a
Titan skating fix to change the way the
lift ability feel for players we'd love
to have a simple fix to this issue we
could roll out immediately but this one
is going to take us a while to land on
something solid and the way they
conclude all these questions to recap we
want to roll out smaller batches of
patches more frequently we want to bring
things up whenever possibly possible but
when we do need to bring something down
we're gonna try and inch it down and
then to the correct location and finally
there is a patch coming it's currently
slated for late January we expect some
changes coming to things like rapid fire
snipers Telesto Nova warp and pre
forsaken subclasses you have much more
plan for the months ahead
so overall with all this length of
questioning everything that you read
here you know the whole bit like what do
you what's your whole thing man like
what do you feel about this approach are
you happy are you like this not enough
where you add I mean in general it's
just nice to see that they're
acknowledging a lot of things that I've
probably heard already I mean they say
Titan skating they say Telesto they say
Scouts I mean stuff that I've had in my
head a lot of them are mentioned here
it's nice to see that they're
acknowledged they're planning them for I
mean sandbox patches we know come later
they're looking at that one in like you
know January at least it's January not
June but I mean they've got some stuff
coming sooner they've got future patches
they've got it listed
I mean Titan skating is one of those
things I mean it's a macro so it's one
of those and I know it's not an easy fix
because I know I think what people do is
they have like the scroll wheel
basically count as jumps and it just
does it so quickly it'd be one of those
that's can you take away a registration
of a jump within like millisecond so it
isn't just acronym and it counts them
all so you like skate it's that weird
and they don't want to break it I
understand so it's like that's one of
those things but I mean that's the first
time they've ever mentioned it
absolutely ever mentioned it so just
acknowledgement is one thing and then
just you know their time of reaction
we'll just have to see how long it takes
for sure absolutely ma'am so what do you
got next ma'am believe all this next
stuff do you that's why why me
I see sleighs and festivities if I could
actually sing I would throw out a
holiday song right now but I'm not gonna
try and well I saw the picture of this
and I about fell out of my chair what is
happening right now we got Santa's
sleigh
this is amazing so whatever I have to do
to get this sparrow I'm getting it
that is the beasty face am I gonna pay a
thousand silver I'll do it okay
this is the most ridiculous barrel in
all of this I have to have it just to
look like crazy sick I mean do you see
this thing it is insane since it is the
most out of control over the top take on
like a Christmas sleigh like it but it's
it's amazing you have to have that
you've gotta own it you gotta pull up on
another Guardian with that Julie Alex
what's up I just like what they need is
like a dawning piece of armor with an
ornament of a Santa hat yes this is
pimped out Santa or elf hat or ears or
give you some boots that have like elf
shoes I want some crazy ornaments for
the style I give you the daunting armor
and then give me some just broken
ornaments I want some dark green with
little like flare coming out of the side
give me some ridiculous stuff like no
that's one thing I think Bungie while it
is like they kind of try and keep
everything somewhat Laura SH and this is
really a stretch leg yes
stretch it farther like just go out
there and give me some elf ears in a
Santa hat and get be stupid about it
just go crazy yeah this is very seasonal
but again kudos we can never not say
enough about the art team man she's
insane they kill it they're like this is
amazing this is they have tremendous
artists and he'd do it again man I guess
stuff we gonna throw money at the screen
it come to donut well we got ah so this
morning we detailed stuff about the
dawning I think I've got it on the next
page there's yeah hello dawning of
course crazy armor very ornate as always
very ridiculous the sleigh looks awesome
I don't even call it experiment called
my sleigh
yes but the dawning is coming so with
the return of even Levante she looks
like she's aged a little bit actually I
think her whole character was redone for
this honestly yeah but she's gonna be
back in the town or managing this we've
got a big giant floating snowflake in
front of the traveler all of those
things are coming are we gonna be
cooking the food so I don't honestly
know how these quests are gonna work
what the purpose of our there's kind of
a fun emote I've seen we're actually
like baked cookies like the little neon
cookie light baked thing that was kind
of cool but all this stuff is it's just
a fun little event like we all wondered
what the dawning was gonna be now after
the haunted forests I'm kind of curious
what the purpose behind this is gonna be
because you've got the haunted forest
you've got a horror story right they
need to give us something to go in here
and work on like hey if I bake cookies
for everybody are they gonna like give
me pieces that craft into some weapon
and hey here you go and there it is I
was literally one scroll down see this
perfect placement on the screen Thanks
and then BAM boom
scroll so you might be asking what do I
do with all these cookies friends you
might be uh throughout the solar system
eager to receive your all your baked
goods they will show their thanks by
rewarding you in their own ways they'll
also be bounties to complete along with
your cookbook here's a preview other
awards enhancement course mods OH
legendary gear and the Avalanche heavy
machine-gun featuring random roles they
are all about the machine guns right now
and I enjoy thunder Lord and I did get
my hammer
I think it's hammer head or machine head
whatever that thing is called that's the
first question do for Forge it has such
a unique sound shadow to the sound team
as well you sound the sound on your
first Forge machine gun sounds they like
they totally stripped it off of an
ac-130 it literally sounds like an old
leg old it sounds like a gun off an
ac-130 like when I played Call of Duty
you had like three different options on
one of those old missions you could pick
which type you'd fire in it
sounds like one of those it sounds so
cool yeah so the hammerhead is like very
very unique gun and hits pretty damn
hard too I haven't put it again really
through its paces but just because I'm
still been trying to level but yeah it's
pretty solid pretty cool so another
machine gun add that to the pile because
I don't know how many more we have
because if we just have like hammer head
the one from black armory with rolls we
need more yeah see it's that you know a
little bit but yeah so we'll be bacon
will be looking fancy that looks looks
good mm-hmm I'm diggin it I'm digging it
yep that's not all while you celebrate
gather your baked goods because towards
and this is like just unlocking the
festival Sparrow so and it says
progressed like is that certain things
is a long quest where you have to do you
know baked goods to every single vendor
in the solar system I'll be kind of
curious what the progression is to get
to this thing but whatever it is doesn't
sound like I can buy it so I'm
definitely have to earn it which is even
better
cellphone Asst mmm your new ride will
come with some very special perks
glimmer boost while boosting the sparrow
spawns a glimmer present every few
seconds until boost runs out glimmer
present presents burst open after only
moments of players can acquire the item
only active during the dawning so a
little glimmer would the player lands a
trick with the sparrow 3 to 5 glimmer
presents are spawned only I could vary
but donning in some introduces some in
time significantly so unfortunately it's
like it's the instant summon which is
perfect it'd be nice if they added a
couple other perks on like you know a
quest barrel like the reload or the
agility or the tricks or something just
to make it like really crazy to go after
but I'm still pretty cool but instant
summon they know is the one so if they
did them that on there they're just
gonna be fired like you but go crazy
enough that you know dedicated bakers
who also have triumphs to pursue of
course triumph trance tramps double
drops so got another this is similar to
the Solstice ship because I yes is
actually putting my hunter close but I
definitely like this ship it's got that
really sleek fighter locator definitely
clean you know
ship reminds me of an old car trauma
eesh but it's an old car - one of my
favorites called yeah
planets and Oh gotcha man if you watch
the enemy got your mind that's where
they got it from
it's that ship all mine love it that is
on my radar I must have that crate that
that sucked in blue and red just like
they got you my ship I'm good to go
you're done I'm done
uh you got your snowball ghost which is
I like it really cool and multiplayer
emotes this is cool I like or is it
looks like it's almost like if you hold
it up in prep and then if the other
person doesn't it like triggers both
yeah yeah that's cool if they start
implementing more it is I mean I could
think of it but the possibilities could
be endless with stuff like this
yeah so keep going yeah yeah cuz they
have the one right now where it's the
drawee mode so you have it down there
and you have to press it again yes so
that's kind of one of those I think
they're trying to work on linking these
together so that's pretty cool and of
course you got the hockey throwdown
gloves offs you know stick down let's do
this yes and then you know what exotic
emote will be exclusive to a bundle
available for direct purchase with the
silver you got the baking dog on oh
there you go cook it up and got some
cookies I don't know I'm glad he's got
gloves on because that probably hurts
but I love all these little neon ones
they're just they're a way to set it
apart sets it on there bakes it out you
actually see them like level out yeah
yes that you actually see the animation
of them like form into cookies like
shrink down cos the original snowballs
from the first dawning will come back
like in strikes and all that good stuff
they don't mention I didn't I don't
think I seen mention of it and that
could have been just their thing for
that one so I mean I haven't seen it if
they do it'd be kind of fun to come back
those were just fun I mean yeah yeah
they'd be like kind of a nice random
thing to have in there because it was
like the snowing effect you slowed him
down and was like all the ads pressed
like the work they put into it more than
anything it was very qualitative away
from I actually like it is there's to be
helpful on strikes and stuff I used to
be effective oh yeah I like slowed down
you you don't run as fast
you stay still mmm but they finally have
a stockpile of bright dust piling up
tests will be offering ingredient packs
in exchange for bright dust if you don't
have a lot of bright dose under worried
otherwise players might be keeping all
the baked goods without having to play
don't worry eva's requires you know
essence of the donnie which can be
acquired during playing activities in
the game so just play you'll be fine
they've always set this stuff up so you
can just play so I think ever verse is
in a good spot and I think that's like I
don't know how much is gonna be in the
dawning these are seasonal events
they're not meant to be crazy they're
cosmetic look pretty the sparrows are
fun the emotes are cool animals see what
the you know baked goods quest grind is
all about but overall I don't think it's
like and that's the thing ever is like
is there gonna be another haunted forest
activity probably not unless they like
throw something else in there cuz it
starts Tuesday like this is so fast it
feels earlier than it ever has before
like this event is because it ends on
January 1st and I feel like it's start
sooner this year than it ever has maybe
it's me but I think it's pretty quick it
feels that way so agree day so write up
writing time with the patch you know
saying so that's gonna bit and I'm a bit
loud truth this work quite full
disclosure I've always liked adorning
armor least the warlocks I love that one
so I want to get that sake because I
love my original but my problem is it
doesn't have any new perks and no you
can't put mods you know I mean yeah I'm
waiting for this bad boy
yep and now you can get a nice fancy set
on PC so we have a lot of patches coming
so just a quick run-through updates
patch 2.1 oh no one was deployed this
week that was all black armory helped
with the more guessing and all that
stuff
patch 2.1 to is coming on December 11th
mmm that is gonna go live they'll cover
a couple of those early fixes probably
gonna bring in the dawning stuff like
that upcoming changes on Tuesday the
black armor officially opens its doors
to the blender Forge the go finish Forge
becomes available in one hour
literally you've got the race for the
scourge of the past as well in one hour
so if you guys want to do that all that
stuff opens at 11:00 a.m. Pacific so
that
coming up them players who you know
they've got the holiday cheer coming
that's gonna go all the way through
January 1st you've got all all year to
play that one just known issues they've
got a couple of them in there the Mars
flash point they said that one is having
some issues right now dropping powerful
gear the blind will matchmaking even
pyro posted that one up pretty quick
he's like is there an issue because he
walked out like ten times they said just
walk slowly
I mean really slowly hugging the right
wall which is a weird thing but maybe
that's just a way to try and get some
matchmaking in there when I play my
hunter at some point need to get my
second one so but also I know
everybody's doing other stuff so blind
was probably just a ghost town at the
moment uh and then couple videos made it
through I haven't really looked at these
yet but I'm sure they're pretty good
yeah that's mostly it we had a quick
runner on patch notes he had your chaos
reach was tuned yes how does have you I
know you actually win you actually
tested the start and stop of it yes yeah
I've tested a lot of it you know it's
very effective um child also are cross
he's got a great video on it right now
as well there's something going on that
I don't know if it's a glitch though but
or it's what they intended now
apparently when you cut it off you know
I think there's a certain point that
when you cut it off it's gonna always
kind of default at about thirty thirty
five percent which is really ends right
above where your class item is your
class ability is and so which is fine if
you go underneath that it'll just stop
at where you stopped it which is fine
which is great one time I wish I
recorded this man and I was with Chi
Basu and scream we're doing a strike and
I want to say I cut it off maybe forty
five percent in or fifty percent in say
about fifty percent in yeah and when I
cut it off again I don't know if this is
a glitch the super started to rise all
the way back up to the top another onion
and I got it again and I'm like whoa
what's going on so I don't know if this
is some secret that apparently like
there's a super super sweet smart but
clearly something
happened I don't know if it should have
happened so I'm gonna travel more
testing with it but um
shout out to uh yeah he wants to shout
to your twitch app because um I was with
you in that stream my first day on PC I
mean well you were in a stream and I was
just in in your audio yeah remembered
you know I was up to that point you know
I'm on I'm getting my new Guardian I'm
trying to get my first see the light and
I'm like which one do I pick which one
do I pick it I should go save go well
yet you know your twitch as like no no
go you know have fun do you know do
Dragon Ball Z dad I picked it man so
much better now like yeah like it not is
to DPS to survivability you know and I'm
gonna get well back but I think I'm
gonna get well back last I'm gonna kick
the Nova what next before that gets not
nerfed in there nom which car last but
yeah I've been having a ton of fun and
this is with no exotics no geo mags no
crown of tempest on that build and it's
been phenomenal so yeah I've been
putting that through the paces and the
last thing I'll say is that um obviously
I played more crucible now you know I've
got more under my belt with the
controller controller game my own man
now I'm it still to be determined
because obviously I'm new to the PC
matchmaking I'm assuming you know it got
me and maybe low e low so I'm not gonna
get gas yet and say oh it's so easy and
PC guys a chat no I'm not going there
but I wouldn't the boy your boy I scream
when you left I got me like two drops
and I got me like a misfit and I never
used the misfit on console but I got
like a decent rolls in moments I'm out
man and I got me a little shoddy I got
me a little um I don't know if it's a
dusk rock or something like that meant
listen just those two alone I'm put out
put in work screen was like yo you going
crazy cause like it almost feels like
something I got or the role I have is
broken aside right but whatever will we
shall see with my controller adventures
as I get deeper as I start doing
competitive as you know things like like
a shot at the speed say Cognito speaking
truth
so you hold me down got me up baby baby
up so um yeah man like we'll see as it
goes on but I will say that the people
can console guys like me who haven't
picked up destiny yet and if you're
worried about it I'll say nah man jump
right in you're gonna feel right at home
you can still take your control you can
still be competitive and to me only
reason why I was losing a lot of
matchups is cuz literally these guys had
meta weapons and I'm literally coming in
here with blues and no exotics and
makeshift guns so once I start to get my
load outs and I don't even have any mods
I'm just coming off of fraud natural and
you know controller stuff so we'll give
it time but child to the PC community
it's so smooth 60 frames different game
all the effects it's just me I cannot go
back to console destiny dude I just
can't do it so this way I'm gonna be and
if y'all wanna find me on battlenet Lord
kognito 1213 holla at me hey it's my
love my ears I got more people coming to
PC like definitely and there's more
people it's like the free people the
free teaser mmm helped quite a few
whether it was the free piece to get
started then you got to buy forsaken or
you just picked it up cuz you actually
had a computer you know like hey it's
free I'll try it for the weekend those
little pieces the teasers they did are
helping sell those pieces those copies
on PC again because I mean somebody like
you you're like nah nah nah okay buy a
console like it took what it took like
days just days and you do you were done
it's the minute you launch it and you
you could just sit in the menu screen
you see the difference usually just sit
loading into planets it's okay I'm so
used to loading into a planet and
pulling out my phone on console cuz I'm
like oh I got time and the only negative
I'm at the nitpick is that in crucible
your match times alone has nothing to do
with the game not operating Corrections
playing another ride that's playing
because I know what icon console I
launched up it's finding me a match
quick on PC you can sit a while you know
I'm saying so yeah man it is but at the
end of the day if you're a fan of this
game you know
you you have the means to make the jump
by all means do it you know means oh and
you don't have to another thing I found
out you don't have to obviously have my
are more podcast on Koran on conical you
don't have to you know um separate them
it'll still exist you can be a part of
two clans so you have a clan on PC it's
still tied to your account as long as
you link them and stuff like that and it
doesn't affect anybody so shout out to
everybody in the clinic yeah Oh see a
chaos reach got its tuning got a couple
of their little pieces damaged required
to destroy tethers little basic stuff
armor and weapons fixes so chromatic
fire just wear explosions we're doing
less damage than intended which that
thing already sounds awesome so that's
better
scavenger perks being fixed high high
impact scout rifles not firing at the
right speed just basic things because
we'll read these I'm not going to hit
them all yeah
got some good fixes though crucible that
caused the mountain top to drop above
appropriate power levels which was for
forsaken donors people couldn't use it
so it was like kind of tagging it wrong
so people are getting kinda couldn't use
like like oh I finally got it crap I
can't use it so that would be no good
gambits a couple good fixes so reduce
the amount of linear fusion rifle power
ammo from 5 to 3 because curcuit Fang
will still put in some work fixed on the
primeval the ascendant primeval like
credit for the proper team which is also
big that would just be a bummer just
basic fixes I'm trying to see if there's
anything else major to touch here for
Theon of course big boy he got fixed but
I wish I could have seen him did you at
least see the clip of it oh I saw the
clip you look good it looks so big he
does literally probably look like
meeting Optimus Prime like absolutely
checkpoints were added to raids well
about that that was a big one mmm
now checkpoints also needed added to
cheddar throne potentially or no resets
checkpoints are in there doesn't reset
because if I'm going through and I'm
working on a specific like one thing
mm-hmm
hey I by myself have to either have
somebody load in else or I have to beat
it so started all over which not an easy
thing to do I did finally finish a solo
shattered throne though
now I didn't do the flawless one that
will be another challenge for the day
but the solo shadow throne was finished
and I had a stream like 40 people I've
watched me do that one nice
I had my fist pump moment and that was
yeah that was like a really cool
accomplishment for me because shadow
throne as I said has been an awesome
piece in knocking out Vargas I got done
with the final piece have you finished
it which are the final piece of what
shadow show you finished finish out and
thrown one yeah
but yeah the last leg Dolan car when I
got to her
we solo to her in about 45 minutes late
I had never been there I figured it out
knocked it out olds literally you get
all the you just have to have the
Knights in order figure out what build
you're gonna do to manage the scions and
then once you get the Knights like
knocked out with a whisper get him down
I had him just about right for health
and then went through a full you know
shield phase broke the crystal and then
it was literally two shots on one pop
the head kill it pop the head kill it
pop that killing picked up the three
orbs and then whisper was 999,999 damage
about 10 times and she died like mmm
that's the way you solo that one so I
mean whispers crucial there as for verga
though thunder Lord is my Savior because
I go Thunder Lord and I had decent ammo
drops and rally barricade just unload
all ever to have 200 mini bullet 200
bulls or so that I haven't got like 265
when I went in first cuz I had a helmet
265 would take him down to under half
okay and then as long as I got some
heavy drop in as I killed all the ads I
got it the second time but the nice
thing about under Lord I can constantly
do damage literally just move my cursor
around take care of the axiom bolts and
never stop firing
it was like an illiterate beef complete
down like complete clip empty like all
260 bullets into him Danu then I'll
shoot him and that's like not quite 2/3
of a cell so he's got some health but it
was a way to manage the Xing bolts and
never stop firing so thunderlord is
perfect for that nice yes that one but
it was like I did the guy I do the
recording but I'll kind of get those up
later towards shadow throne coming up
next time because right now it'd be like
not much to do with it so yeah
absolutely
a couple other pieces like this patch is
literally like this patch notes that
they have they're about to change like
this was
priming creams will not appear more
frequent for players under 550 right
there's about to go to 600 like all
these things are changing so next week
we'll get some more what's ups now
though how you doing man yeah so and
then they got checkpoints to fix an
issue with like certain activities not
displaying correctly so pretty basic
stuff
overall let me ask back back up one
thing is just two things I wanted cuz I
know we gotta foremost finish up um
one that you overlooked was the when we
talked about the rain completion they
added for Leviathan the arm the prestige
versions no longer requires standard
completion and that's a big deal only
from the standpoint for you guys what
trying to chase catalyst eater of world
has the Telesto catalyst and for those
guys like me who want to get your sleep
as cameras please this is the time
because at the end of the day you know
you know if you've been you know happy
didn't do them and you had to do the
regular and then you can I'll unlock the
prestige that's a big deal and then I
want it when you scroll down I want you
to arm to hit that one about the what
you call the deceit of light now with
the CEO right here yeah so is that was
that how it what always was as far as
the um the blind well and stuff like
that seeing of light added to the drop
table for blind well heroic and me
that's I actually would have to test
that with my hunter because yeah well no
I finished up all in line there no I
haven't got the I didn't do the tier two
but I guess now that's another place to
get your third seat of light because
they know that she's on the three week
cycle and if new and this is me because
again I've only got one seed I need my
two subclasses so part of me is like I
should just wait until Tuesday because I
was gonna ask you this question like
should I like is this that means here to
know but this is in effect now so tier
twos always been there tier two is where
you've got it the first time and then it
was either the raid or you had to finish
your quest and go talk to Mara saw right
so now it looks like it's added to the
heroic version of I don't know if that's
like your third one so you got your fans
here three
as like you get it for sure maybe I went
through I went through on my hunter and
I finished the quest and talked to her
but I still never my tier 2 and we
finished tier 3 and then we also turned
around and finished Brooke but now
apparently you can get it for her I
guess it's what it sounds like it was
adding to the drop table so maybe you
don't have to try and see if my hunter
grant if nobody's in there right now my
that might be an issue but like once
blind oil becomes like back and active
and sounds like where you're gonna be
getting your seat of light so yeah let
me know when you get back in here and
present need them seeds like I got to do
it on my hunter too so at some point
we'll have to both work on that together
just you know it's like I'm high enough
where I could probably manage a row you
got a you probably whatever think would
be immune to you in there so be there if
you find a good group doing it and I
even went in there with my hunter when
it was low because I was just trying to
grind everything out yeah and I was just
trying to get the percentage done yeah
and I ended up actually just being with
groups who did tier 3 I could do some
damage then I went heroic and they were
immune but as long as stood in the room
yeah that's all you got to do it exactly
nice cool woman yeah well like overall
it's it's like you know we talked about
a lot of stuff we had our entry to the
Annual Pass lunch and I guess the other
thing to talk about it's like I don't
know how things feel for there's gonna
be new mods with the raid yes there are
now this is one thing what laughs you
done your quest I want to know people
who have black armory or who don't have
black armory somebody out there have not
black armory
started the quest with 8:01 because I've
asked for this forever and I'm like hey
what the hell do I do with my gun Smith
materials I can buy mod c'mon I'm
falling it's from her but to do that I
couldn't buy them until I finished the
forge for the first time and I can't
give the forwards without black armory
so if you can't buy mod components to
use up all the gunsmith materials you
have without that that is a that is an
issue for me because everybody can use
mod components if
she's just gonna be a vendor in the
tower you can do a quest it should not
require you access to the Forge just to
buy mod components now maybe you don't
have access to the new ones okay that's
a choice but just to buy Ahmad
components as a vendor selling them that
should not be limited behind black
armory that is one thing I do remember
and was looking I was like oh like that
that shouldn't be that way and maybe if
it is it won't stay long but I think if
that is the case that's definitely a
mistake because that's a limiting factor
that's really kind of cruel no
completely grew you know completely on
the money with that and that definitely
change because that's a five vital
commodity you know I'm saying like
people need those things that's the only
resource where you can get components
unless I'm listening the screen and I'm
going into my collections and
dismantling blues for hours
you know like that's just yeah I mean
that's that's crazy yeah that's one of
those things and it's like right now
this is the again I hate to say it but
it's like we will see time will tell
more like well more time has to pass
before I can say hey do we have more
guns because we were saying the loop
pool was fairly small okay there are
gonna be more things you get from the
forges and stuff but like the general
loop pool out in the world is still not
getting much love and that's one thing
like I think we'd rather said it before
or I've thought it or other people have
said it they need to start adding either
add some of the old gun in guns in with
random roles unlike patches and be like
hey we threw like another set of weapons
in loophole just to give more random
roles a few more things just a few more
options so I'm not truly still getting
like my tenth ten paces or something
like that like just we need some more
options in there and we'll kind of see
how this progresses but right now I
think for all you guys listening to say
hey do I get the annual pass right now
honestly if you love destiny and you're
gonna do the grind you know there's
gonna be a lot of stuff to do I'm gonna
be a lot of stuff to hopefully enjoy the
raid the forges they are gonna be cool
there's just gonna be some grind
involved to feel like I'm on the fence I
don't know that's harder one for me to
honestly say yeah this is the time to do
it maybe three months from now be like
hey jump in and enjoy all of it all at
once cool what I would say is for
everyone this is the time to buy
forsaken
work your way enjoy the game enjoy the
story enjoy the grind try and get up to
600 and then when you feel like you're
ready then annual past might be time but
if you just buy late for a second annual
pass together and you're like oh what am
i doing that's like a murder oh that's
real that's real I completely agree I
think I think that's some great advice
for people looking in from the outside
in yeah and for those you guys out there
on both sides if you've got anybody who
hasn't played the game yet hasn't picked
up forsaken slow-mo if you're still
sitting out there because I know you're
not really huge a destiny person I've
got copies of the Forsaken collection
you want some giveaways so watch Twitter
or watch my YouTube page I'm gonna be
doing them just kind of a different ways
one might be a little hidden video so
you might actually have to find them a
couple be more obvious but I'm gonna do
copies because forsaking is a great
experience so that's what I do want
people to experience can I say like yeah
go on by the annual pass tomorrow say
that because I know one knows and is
still up in the air but forsaken is
worth every penny and that's um I think
like all should experience because four
seconds story the end game the grind
like the way the weapons feel the gun
like the whole experience of everything
you get with d2 forsaken like for me D
to launch all the way through that's a
cool experience absolutely that's why I
think like if you have an experience
that it's a lot of it's a lot of fun
there's a lot of cool stuff in there so
just want to throw that out there for
you guys you got anything else I mean I
think we've I know we've eclipsed to
ours easily that was yeah this long
point yeah me know you literally said it
all I mean like I said we it's gonna be
interesting to see how they handle
moving forward you know with uh the
black armory we both said what we have
to say we're in agreement pretty much
I'm coming curious to see how Tuesday's
patch affects things you know I'm gonna
be trying to catch a little bit of that
raid see how guys are doing probably at
the rate I think it may be tomorrow
morning the guys is still going but who
knows and I just wonder if they're 6:50
it may not be that hard yeah if there's
650 or take of they confirm are your
guys that like already I mean I'll just
literally move it over so I can show it
to you it's on okay yeah destiny tracker
oh yeah I mean you got Grenadier Jake on
xbox he's up there
Oh like you look through the list of
people who are up there but yeah these
are 650 you've got four of them why lazy
649 they're tied for fifth 648 67 86 645
I'm in the top 84 stop so 641 Wow Esso
is up there yeah Wow look how many these
guys part of glads chant-like clan I
know he's in there
so I mean this is 186 there so 637 and
it's 6:40 recommended you're only 13
from the top Jesus so I mean that's how
it's really this raids getting beaten
nevermind what to call those guys were I
mean there were all those ones that mean
glads group before that beat it last
time for last wish
yeah where's that so do you see him on
the list yes he necessary coop dude
he's trying to figure out where to spot
number looks like was it 19 or somebody
was up there he's way up there he's way
up there and shout out guys esoteric if
you want to see somebody who is just
like unreal yeah he's like 98 thousand
subs right now see if we can push him
over a hundred mm-hmm because he
deserves it to the work he puts in like
no lifing honestly the dude is like just
crazy to watch so he is such a beast to
be soloing Forge content I am convinced
that is not a human being he never
speaks always use text that is an
Android Skynet I'm telling you esoteric
is not human he's just ungodly it's just
things that he does that I just don't
understand humanly possible monster so
yeah shut him out so you can get him a
little love spread the word if you want
to see some impressive content that like
yeah he'll do solo stuff and I'll do
solo stuff but I promise you it's a very
different experience I'm gonna I'm gonna
walk you through how to do it he's gonna
show you how it should be done to the
artificial intelligence
oh but yeah I mean he's 648 you got gigs
is 648 you got I mean all these like you
know I don't know how long this thing's
gonna last so Ray's getting beaten and
in like an hour two hours that's good
yeah so the mechanic and this is where
it's getting this is gonna be a very
interesting thing for people who like do
these little cheese's and get up to the
top and save the engrams and all that
type of stuff is this how you is and
this will be the question is how Bungie
wants their rates to go they want it
like this is this is this disc
representative of the best you know
again you know they gonna have to
they're gonna have to answer these
questions you know come what is it a
season of the of the drifter and you
know um you know that that that's all I
want to see because at the end of the
day you know if as long as they gate
things correctly you know it shouldn't
have to come down to things like this
you shouldn't have to come down to using
these exploits and doing Engram holding
and whatever guys are doing let's just
see how it goes you know be like hey
what do you play a man right now on
playing destiny this is expansions about
to come out oh cool it's like you know
I'm pretty comfortable let me pick this
thing up I'll get the annual pass as
well wait what like that's the
experience that's gonna go on so those
are not a coochie
I liked about last wish is they they
didn't have those things in place and
you waited a week they pushed it back a
week right and it was just two weeks so
I've just grinding right so if at the
time you couldn't you can get in there
like I I thought the way they handled
last wish was perfect I don't have any
problems with that you know I'm saying
like if obviously after no life it no
doubt yeah Matt didn't know life of to
see if we didn't have the time you
weren't gonna get enough to get past
maybe the first a second but at least
some people were able to take it to the
first encounter unlike black armory
yeah I mean that's really like people
what like even I could have probably was
no I was like I don't know if I could
have done even the first in Canada I was
still probably pretty low but there was
a decent amount of people who got
through like that did they beat it
no but that the first encounter gets
seen and viewed and will
some success was had because yeah that
was that was kind of the difference of
all of that stuff it was like but that's
also the raid like you know that's not
just like hey here's a piece of content
and I know it's meant to be in game but
yeah just as you said they got to see it
and it's there's some balancing there's
some balancing too - I agree I agree
Coleman mmm-hmm but yeah I think that's
pretty much where we're gonna wrap it up
today guys it's been awesome thank you
guys all for hanging out today it was
cool Chad's a lot of stuff a lot of
talks a lot of lots of thoughts as
always vagabonds some of you guys have
been here for pretty much all the two
hours so you guys are crazy
in the best way if you have not followed
me yet here on Twitch I'd be surprised
most you guys probably have but I'm
about twenty eight away from a thousand
followers oh let's get that going
yeah so on my twitch channel we're
pretty close to a thousand followers so
that's awesome
so just the support lately has been
amazing guys like I had I mean I would
have to look back in the last like three
months but my youtube channel twitch
those have exploded so just the support
from you guys has been awesome and it
just keeps going so shout out to iron
Lords podcast as well man the man of the
intros the man of like making people
feel humbled when you you can't even
live up to the intro and then just
honestly the deep dives the questions
just the way I love long-form podcasts
when you get guests to open up and
that's something you guys do so so well
like I love shout out to it's Chris
Hardwick his podcast is just with like
celebrities and stuff a little for
movies but it's like an hour long
usually the good ones are maybe a little
over and you get them on those long not
like the 5 minute like little blip
questions here they're they really go
into stories and open up and you guys do
that exact same stuff you get them
talking about old-school gaming what
they came through crazy stories of like
their histories and like every one of
those every one of those guys do you
like you you just you hit the right
button so with them and you have enough
knowledge to know what to ask to get
them to go deep and it works so else I
mean shout outs iron Lords podcast guys
listen to them follow on I know you guys
are you guys past a thousand yet as well
yeah we're about at nine
in 25 both of the nines we need a
thousand thousand bowls if you guys are
in my twitch chat go follow iron Lords
podcast if you like the long form and
you're sitting here go follow them
because they got some really if you just
are a gamer just go enjoy it they always
got some good love good humor and good
good interviews all those guests are
awesome so much appreciate it man you
know I'll do my outro trend again shout
the Bronte's man please support I'm a
guy's fantastic shot the Forte it's up
to you today you know I'm glad people
are starting to get the word out I've
known for a long time you're not saying
I met the game at Guardian Connor you
know I said I knew this guy's the real
deal and it's good to see his growth
it's been tremendous so good to see that
my community actually recognizes you and
people are telling me hey I use your
content I'm a solo destiny plan shoutout
to the tooth 2 HD in a chat he says
lucky you you guys are the shows the
reason why I jump back in you know I'm
saying it's really cool to see people
now getting into in tune with you and in
it's dope man because a lot of people
some people don't have Clint some people
don't have a lot of friends to play with
and they watch me bounce this video and
you get that simplified breakdown on
what to do effective things to do and at
the same time you know a lot of people
he doesn't assume that you're this
hardcore person like he will break
things down even to even deserve videos
and things that you don't know about
weapons and exotics you don't know about
he's like hey this is you know he's got
me using risk runner in certain parts a
gambit now I I wasn't even doing it
because of you know of a buzzer so good
to see the growth man both trying to go
this thing together as far as me you
already know on Twitter actually is at
more Cognito on battlenet Lord Lord
Cognito
12 number 12 13 so one two one three
please check me out man shout to scream
those are my new Forte I know we got a
link I added you if you're on PC please
add me we got a great bunch of guys
there and shout out to Mike Ibarra and
the spawnpoints clan also shout out a
clan um legendary emblems only yeah it's
full right now so yeah shout out to you
guys you guys saying guys
been running with them a lot of fun
finally get a chance to play with my man
so that's good and obviously this
Sunday's farzana podcast every Sunday is
the Lord's Day Sunday 11 a.m. Eastern
Standard on the iron wanna podcast
channel we will have the young lord ptk
blam from the shop podcast he's a good
up-and-coming youtuber great content
we're gonna talk about a lot of things
or talk about the game awards game if
what they said this man is a traitor I
have expanded my destiny horizons to PC
call me that's the pcs answer I've heard
from anybody in my life
I've expanded my horizons onto the world
of PC I am a well-versed in all forms of
dusty and thank you I like to broad my
knowledge for the game that I've said my
ass it looks pretty a hashtag exposed
with the college value bond his job you
put me through college so now I got a
stay here
yes single player self is experienced
shoot out the to go down but yeah shout
out the PT k blam he'll be on this
Sunday 11 a.m. Eastern Standard Time we
talk about the game Awards all these
things going on with the latest consoles
PlayStation PC Xbox the next-gen is a
lot of stuff to talk about and deep dive
please catch us and of course you
already know the best two-man team in
destiny flashpoint every Friday 9:00
a.m. Eastern Standard Time here on my
channel as well as one twitch any party
so that's all I got that's it I mean you
guys know where to find me it's you bond
us on everything
if you guys need my battle pack you
Broncos 1305 other than that it's twitch
Twitter ebon toast and then YouTube you
guys know where to find me if you
haven't followed both of us follow both
subscribe to the channels we got good
content coming for you guys usually I
just like to have a lot of fun enjoy it
and yeah I feel like destiny like gaming
I've got an alpha potentially look into
so when you guys giveaways man so I can
get my console guys to come over I got
two for PC and the one for PlayStation
and one for Xbox cuz I love that way so
those will be coming so you
just follow me on Twitter that will be
one place to watch it for sure and then
YouTube as well so I'll be letting you
guys know about that one for some in the
coming future I'm trying to find a good
time to kind of want to put it in a
video kind of get it like set in a
certain place so that stuff will be
coming so stay tuned and other than that
you guys are awesome you've been a lot
of fun two and a half hours is a long
time to deal with us yes which guys are
great so on that note I will see you
guys soon
adios alrighty peace